يا دكتور انا رحت وخلصت واشتراكي اشتركت
سنه وما رحت غير شهر شهرين ليش في فكره
سائده اللي هي ما ينفع تتمرن حديد
الا لما تنحف عشان ما ينفع تبني
العضلات على الشحوم ما لها علاقه طب انت
من فين جايب العلم هذا معلش يعني
مين ايش مصدرك في هذا الكلام كله والله
مصدري فلان مين فلان فلان واحد معضل
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح
اغلب الناس وانا منهم عنده المعاناه مع
الوزن وضبط الوزن وما في احد راضي عن وزنه
النحيف واللي وزنه زايد يبي ينحف المشكله
ان ما في احد يقول لك كيف الحل مو هنا
المشكله بالضبط المشكله ان في ناس تقول لك
عندها حلول لكن كل واحد يقول عندي حل
مختلف وكل واحد منهم يقول ان حلي هو الحل
الصحيح والباقي غلط من الضحيه احنا
وانا ادري اهميه الصحه قبل الوزن في حلقات
كثيره تكلمنا فيها عن هذه المسائل لكن في
طرح جديد بسيط لحل مشكله الوزن كيف تخسر
الوزن بدون انظمه قاسيه ولا كيتو ولا بطيخ
وين المشكله اللي تؤثر على زياده الوزن في
مجتمعنا فضيفي يمر عليه اكثر من 500 مراجع
في عيادته شهريه والاكيد ان قدر يشكل تصور
عن السلوكيات السيئه وكيف نقدر نغيرها
للوصول الى حياه صحيه ووزن مثالي ضيفي في
هذه الحلقه الدكتور فيصل بن سعود طبيب
اسره واخصائي تحكم وزن يتحدث بشكل رائع
بسيط بكل انسان عادي ما يجبرك على ترك او
الالتزام بنموذج معين ولا يبغاك تروح
تتمرن لياقه بساعات ولا تشيل حديد باوزان
وطريقه محدده عند نظام يقول انه هو النظام
الصحي المفترض كل الناس تمشي عليه
قبل ان نبدا الحلقات ما نصورها بشكل مباشر
ونسجلها بالعاده بوقت سابق وننشرها في
الوقت اللي نشوفه انسب فهذه الحلقه
صورناها قبل رمضان فادروا وجود القهوه
والمويه
ودي تشارك الحلقه مع اي احد تعرفه يعاني
من الوزن على الارجح بتكون حلقه مفيده قد
تغير حياته اما الان
لنبدا
والله اذا شربت الان كمان
طلبات القلب حزين
يعني في ناس يعني اعلن القهوه توقعتي عندك
فلسفه في القهوه يعني مدري مين قال لي انت
قلتي
بس عشان يكون معك في الصوره طيب قولي كن
معاي في الصوره اول شيء لانك تورطت في هذا
المعرفه تعرفه
تركي يا حبيبي بانه صديق مشترك
يعني في كذا اهتمامات دخلت في النص هل كل
الناس تسولف معك الاكل للاسف والله
كل الناس تعني منك صح
وكل احد يقول كلام مختلف عن الثاني مظبوط
يعني مثلا يمكن
ما ادري شفت حلقه عمار
ايش رايك في رده
تقول اذا ما عجبتك انها خليني اقول لك اول
شيء هو اعطاء سرديه مختلفه
حلو
بسيطه تقدر تفهمها وتقدر تعرف كيف تتعامل
معها تبدو منطقيه انا ما ادري عن كيف تبدو
جدا منطقيه يعني
فكل المطلوب منك انك لا تخربطوا الاكل
ومعروف ان يعني هو يقول لي ان كل اي شيء
على شكله الطبيعي كما خلقه الله
ودائما نسمع ان التغيرات اللي تسافر
الهرمونات عند الحيوانات ولا في كيف
يدخلون الاكل يسير يعني الشركات هذه انه
يؤثر بشكل باخر على كيف الانسان يتلقى
ويؤثر على
بسيطه كل الاكل طبيعي
بس يعني
تبغى تنحف ابد اخر بس وجوده الفطور وهذه
الصدق يعني اللي كلمني يمكن ثلاثه او
اربعه ومنهم يعني صديقي يعني ما عاد
يقول انها غيرت حياته واغلبهم كذا انه
غيرت حياتها
بس بالنسبه لي احس انها صعبه التنفيذ عمار
في القصيم هو عايش في مزرعه فالتحديات حقت
الحياه المعاصره ما هي بعده ما تنطبق علي
فما قدرت امشي معه بالضبط هذا هو الكلام
المنطقي اصلا يعني انت لما تقول كلام طيب
ناكل الاكل على صوره الطبيعي طب اذا وزنه
ما نزل
بس فين الخلل اذا وزنه ما نزل
اتوقع اغلب اللي غيرت حياته من وزنه اللي
الشباب اللي كلمتهم يعني معاذ
سبع كيلو يعني من وقت الحلقه الى الان
يعني مستمر على النظام
مبسوط يعني
نزول الوزن ترى مره سهل
اسهل شيء ممكن تتخيل انك تعمله انك تنزل
وزنك الصعوبه فين تحافظ على الوزن
تنزيل كل الناس في مرحله ما قدروا ينزل
وزنهم بس ما هو مو كلهم قدروا يحافظوا على
وزنهم وهي هنا المشكله
وهو هنا اللي لازم نشد حيل انا ونوعي فيه
الناس
تثبيت الوزن ومحافظه في الوزن
لانه هذه هي الاستدامه نزور الوزن هذا شيء
مؤقت كان اقدر اعطيه لك نظام غذائي كل
الاكل على صورته الطبيعيه
مؤقتا سافرت
خرجت مع الشباب
رحت زواج
كيف اطبق
ما راح تقدر
فهذه تعتبر وحده من الانظمه الغذائيه
اللي هي كل الاكل على صوره الطبيعيه
مناسب للبعض ممتاز استمر انت بيئتك تساعدك
تستمر على هذا الشيء روح استمر بالعكس هو
هذا يعني هذا المطلوب منك لكن افضل نظام
غذائي
موجود هو النظام الغذائي اللي تقدر تستمر
فهذا يفيد شخص بس ما يفيد الشخص الثاني
فانا ما اقدر اعمم هذه النظام على كل
الناس وهذا الكلام ينطبق على كل الانظمه
الغذائيه طيب دحين
هل نظام
عمار خطا ولا غير قبل التطبيقات هذه
مشكلتك معه
النظام ما في شيء ما في شيء المعلومات
وشيطنه
السكر او بعد المنتجات الغذائيه هذه اللي
عندي مشكله فيها زي ايش
انت قلت لي انك صريح يعني
تحديد الاما بيتكلموا على السكر او
الاطعمه مثلا المصنعه المكرونه الامور هذه
كلها هذه يعني موجوده يعني في حياتنا بشكل
يومي يعني
في سبب او حكمه من انه ليش هذا الشيء احنا
مو مره نفضله
مقياس الشبع
الان اذا اكلت مكرونه مثلا هذه من الاطعمه
اللي هي تعتبر المصنعه
بعد مده بسيطه راح تجوع فاذا جعلت راح
تاكل مره ثانيه
فتفكيرهم كامل على المكرونه انه المكرونه
هي سبب زياده الوزن طب اذا الشخص اكلها
باعتدال
هل يقدر هل وزنه راح يزيد لا ما راح يزيد
لانه كيف الواحد اصلا وزنه يزيد
هنا في اعتقادات مره كثيره
توقيت الطعم
يفرق
شفت انا بجيك بنفس الكلام اللي بسمعه في
العياده والله يا دكتور انا
اغلب اكله في المساء
اكل وانا طب رمضان
رمضان اغلبك لانه مسائي ومع ذلك في ناس
بينحفوا
في ناس وهم بيزيد اغلب الناس تزيد بس
عارفين ليش بيزيد
المقالي
الاكل طوال الوقت
الفطور بعد الفطور انت
اخترت مده من المغرب الى الفجر وفي مفتاح
وفين مفتوح غير المشروبات
المشروبات تعتبر تزود الوزن اسرع
او تساعد على زياده الوزن اسرع عشان يكون
دقيقي في الكلام
فهذه من المعتقدات اللي هو التوقيت يجي
ناس يتكلموا على صنف معين والله الرز
يزود الوزن
كبسات البخاري المعرفه ايش كل هذه الاصناف
في اليابان
حسب ما احصائيه شفتها يعني قريب
اعتقد معدل تناول الرز عندهم اكثر من
عندنا للفرد
ومع ذلك نسبه السمنه في اليابان
ثلاثه في المئه
كم عندنا نسبه السمنه والوزن الزائد
اتجاوزت الستين في المئه
اشوف كم ضعف حل المشكله من الرز لا
المشكله ايش الاضافه اللي مع الرز
السمن
كميه الزيت
يعني وما في مقارنه اصلا في الطعم احنا
عندنا اطعم اكل في العالم
بدليل
كثير من الناس اللي هم يجوا بس عشان
يشتغلوا في السعوديه ترى
وزنهم بيزيد
عشان الاكل نفسها ما هي متوازنه فمثلا اذا
جينا نتكلم عن الكبسه
يعني في ناس بيدخلوا في العياده بيقول لي
انا اكل كبسه يوميا
وانا صرت في البيت اكل كبسه يومين
لكن المشكله فين
كميه الرز اللي قاعد تحطها كم كميه الدجاج
اللي قاعد تحطها اول لحم بشكل عام
فلما اجي اسال الشخص انا ايش والله ايش
اتغديت اليوم يقول لي رز فهو اصلا اهتمامه
وتفكيره في هذه الوجبه انه الاساس عنده
الرز بينما لما تيجي تسال واحد
رياضي او يتمرن ايش اتغديت اليوم يبدا لك
يقول لك دجاج لانه هذا الاساس هو فاهم انه
هذا الاساس
فالكبسه وجبه ممتازه جدا
وصحيه اذا اكلتها بالطريقه الصح كيف اكلها
بالطريقه الصح طيب كيف اكلها بالطريقه
الصح لازم تكون كميه الدجاج او اللحم بشكل
عام
اكبر من كميه الرز
مثال بس كذا تخيلي كيف تاكل البرجر
خبز خبز لحم خبز
طب كيف تاكل الكبسه رز
دجاج
فاذا احنا حناكل البرجر بنفس طريقه الكبسه
حيصير خبز خبز خبز خبز خبز خبز لحم خبز
خبز خبز خبز كيف حتك البرجر بهذا الشكل
فهمت فنفس الوجبه شكلها غير منطقي بس احنا
عشان اتعودنا عليها بهذا الشكل
كيف تاكلها انت في البيت
انا عارف كميتي يعني انا خلاص قد حسبت انا
ايش الاحتياج حقي فاعمل لي كوب واحد
قدر الضغط طبعا شغال ما يوقف
وهنا اللي بقى المعلومه اللي بعدهم
ينصدموا فيها مني انا اكل دجاجه كامله
ماشي
جلسه واحده
لو تشوف كميه الرز
بديه واحده بس كميه البروتين اللي انا
قاعد اكله كميه كبيره الجسم ما يخزن
البروتين البروتين ما يتخزن كل خليه في
جسمك تستفيد من البروتين
بينما الرز يعتبر من النشويات والنشويات
تتحول الى سكر والسكر في النهايه اصلا
هدفه الاساسي انه يتخزن ويصير طاقه
بشكل عام
انجح طريقه تنزل فيها وزنك من غير ما تحسب
سعرات ومن غير ما تغير الدنيا كلها زود لي
كميه البروتين اللي موجوده في اكلك ايش
البروتين هنا المشكله
انه لما نيجي نتكلم
في السوشيال ميديا
هذول ناس يعرفوا يستخدموا الانترنت
خصوصا حقين تويتر
اكثر ناس يعرفوا يدوروا
طب الناس اللي ما لهم في تويتر الناس اللي
ما لهم في السوشيال ميديا
فئه كبيره ما اعرف شو اصلا البروتين ما
يعرف ايش هو الكربوهيدرات النشويات ما
يعرفش الدهون
فلما نيجي نقول زود لي البروتين لازم نوضح
ايش هو البروتين زود لي اللحوم بشكل عام
حمراء بيضاء
عندك كمان
يعني داخلين حتى على السماك
زود لي
[موسيقى]
البيض
هذه المصادر الحيوانيه طب في المصادر
النباتيه عندك الفول عندك الحمص عندك
العدس زود هذه وقلل من النشويات وراح تنحف
بشكل تلقائي
طيب انا بدي التفاصيل كذا
برجع يعني
عمار لانه كان عنده نظام
[موسيقى]
يعني احس انه اللي جالس انت تسويه الحين
واللي هو يسويه هو مثال حقيقي لمعاناتي
معاناه ايمن معاناه اتكلمنا عليها لان كل
واحد يقول كلام
مو بس انه يقول هذا الصح لا وهذاك غلط
[موسيقى]
فليش اصلا هذا التباين في مساله الغذائيه
ليش الى الان مع كل التطور العلمي كل
العلوم الا انها تبقى هذه الافكار
المختلفه من ناس معتبرين يعني اقدر اخذ
كلامك لانك معتبر اخذ دكتور عمار برضو
المعتبر وين ما تروح يعني كل احد جالس
يعطي فكره لنظام غذائي واحد يقول لك
الكيتو واحد يقول لك السياره متقطع واحد
يقول لك النباتي واحد يجي يقول لك
كيف فكل واحد يقوله عندها
ما يدعمه علميا بانه مناسب بس الاخير
بعضها ما تشتغل او بعض ما تناسب او بعضها
الاخر يشوف خطا
الفاصل في هذا الموضوع
هو الشخص الممارس تمام الكلام العلمي جدا
سهل والنظري جدا سهل
لما اجي انا اعطيك معلومات او اي شخص يبغى
يقرا عن هذا الموضوع لو التحكم في الوزن
كل المعلومات اللي راح تطلع فيها تصب في
مكان واحد اللي هو داخل جسمك اللي هو
تغذيه والحركه
لازم نغير في الاكل ولازم نغير في الحركه
وهذا غير كافي لانه اذا انا اعطيتك نظام
سواء مني او من شخص اخر انت راح تفشل فيه
طفينا المشكله اذا انا قاعد اعطيك الكلام
العلمي وفلان بيعطيك الكلام العلمي ليش
بيمشي معاك ما بيمشي مع هذا او العكس
هنا الصوره الكامله اللي هي ايش في امور
الشخص هو سببها وفي امور الشخص ما هو
سببها خارج جسم الانسان
مثال البيئه
العامل النفسي
لما اتكلم عن البيئه اتكلم عن العلاقات
داخل المنزل
المشاكل الاسريه
ممكن تولد اللي هو الاكل العاطفي
بيئه العمل
كل يوم خارجين داخلين بدونات او حلا مكان
الاصحاب يلا نخرج ناكل يلا او بيئه الشخص
انه كل يعني ما شاء الله علاقاته كثيره
لازم يوجب
المنطقه اللي هو فيها ما فيها مشي ما فيها
حركه اصلا ما في مواصلات عامه ما في درج
ما في ولا اي حاجه
فنرجع للموضوع الاساسي اللي هو فين
المشكله
لما يجيني شخص المفترض
افهم كيف صوره حياته بشكل عام
وافيده في هذه النقاط وهذا يفرق بين
المدرب الناجح
والمدرب اللي حافظ
وينقل كلام
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار
المزيد في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
يعني في مدربين لما يسوق لنفسه يقول لك
بعد نتائج او نتائج خمسميه مشترك 600
مشترك طب انا في العياده عندي
متوسط عدد المراجعين 25 مريض في اليوم
في الشهر يوصلوا 500
وانت بتتكلم على 500 شخص بيجيني
اذا قلنا
حناخذ النسبه حق اللي هي السمنه والوزنه
الزائده اللي هي 60% 60% منهم عندهم سمنه
فانا قاعد اشوف الملاحظات هذي
فال500 اللي انت فرحان فيها في مسيرتك
انا قاعد اشوفها في الشهر فحتى لو انا شخص
غير مهتم او ضعيف الملاحظه
راح الاحظ امور
ما حد بيتكلم فيها اصلا
فهذا الفرق لما اجي انا اقول لك
الفاصل في هذا الموضوع الممارسه هل انت
فعلا
بتمارس ولا مجرد
تكتب محتوى
وتنزله للناس
ويجوك ناس اصلا هم جاهزين
للتغيير فاحنا لما نقول جاهزين للتغيير
هنا الحلقه الفاصله اللي هي ايش
جاهز للتغيير يعني احنا بنتدخل الان في
السلوك
السلوك هذه تعتبر كانها جلسات نفسيه
انا عشان اساعدك تتغير التغير له خمسه
مراحل
في مرحله اللي هي ما قبل اللي يسموها ما
قبل التامل
اللي هي ايش يعني يعني انت اساسا ما انت
داري انه عندك مشكله
كيف حغيرك كيف حقنعك اصلا وانت شايف انه
ما عندك مشكله يا حبيبي انا مبسوط وهذه
موجوده عند مين عند الشباب لا
ما تظهر الامراض في هذا الوقت او نادرا
تظهر الامراض هذا الوقت
وفي المرحله اللي بعدها اللي هي التامل
كنت اللي هي ايش يقول لك
والله داري
عادي
هذا صعب ان انا اغير فيه
واغلب اللي بيجوا في العياده هم من هذه
المرحلتين
هنا يباني مين المدرب الناجح انه لما يجي
شخص شبه مهزوز بس دوب واخذ خطوه
حافظ عليه غيره ابني في عادات تستمر معه
مو اعطي له جدول يلا روح يخلص من الجدول
يلا ارجع لي فكذا صار الشخص معتمد على هذا
الشخص انا ما غيرت سلوك انا ما غيرت حياه
هذا الشخص
وهذا واحد من الاسباب اللي خلاني يعني
اوقف السيارات
لانه لاحظت
انه في جانب انا احتاج اتطور فيه مره
اللي هو الجانب السلوكي
لازم احاول افهم الشخص هذا ولازم انا
احاول اكون داعمله فصعب متعب جدا ما هو
سهل
وهنا دور الاخصائيين النفسيين
حقهم ضايع
ايش اقصد
اغلب الناس اللي ما هم قادرين يغيروا
سلوكهم او عندهم عادات خاطئه هذول يحتاجوا
يعني ما اقول يحتاجوا خاطئه
عادات خاطئه مثلا
نتكلم عن التدخين ولا ما له علاقه لا
علاقه نعم
ممكن نخلي له علاقه اذا ابغى اوصل الفكره
كيف يعني
التدخين جانا شخص مثلا مدخن ونبغى نساعده
يبطل التدخين
التدخين مشكلته نوعين
ادمان النيكوتين
وهذا مره سهل نتخلص منه
في ادويه
محبوبه او لصق نساعده انه يتخلص من
النيكوتين
طيب خلص من النكتين انطرد النكتين من جسمه
تماما دمه صافي
يرجع يدخن مره ثانيه سلوك العاده يا سلام
هنا دور العاده في هذا الشخص اذا ما
اشتغلنا على هذا الجانب راح يرجع لنفس
الموضوع خلاص هذا زي البرنامج
اذا اعطيته المحفزات او الظروف المناسبه
راح يرجع لهذه العاده عشان كذا احنا
عارفين انه اي شخص عنده سلوك خاطئ مره سهل
انه يصير له انتكاسه وش السلوكيات الخاطئه
في الاكل يعني واضح
بالدخان يعني كيف اثره
والعاده بس يعني
حد عنده عاده انه ياكل
اكل خاطب وما يقدر يتوقف عنه ولا ايش هذه
تحصل في اللي هي السناكات
في عادات كثيره بتمر عندي في العياده من
اشخاص مثلا
كيس مكسرات حاطه في السياره معه
وهو رايح وهو جاي ما هو قادر يوقف
متاثر على الوزن طبعا
بشكل جدا كبير ممكن تكون
الدهون صحيه يعني ممتاز يعني بيكون
يعني
مدري ايش يعني حلو الجوز لوز انت فتحت باب
مره مهم
من المعتقدات الخاطئه اللي هي ايش صحي
يعني اخذه بكميه مفتوحه الجسم ترى ما يفرق
صحي مو صحي
دخل الجسم محسوب عليك
بس ما يفرق يعني ما يقدر يعرف جسمي انه
هذا صحي بيتعامل معه بشكل مختلف عن غير
صحي الا وهي عشان كده احنا لما نجي نقول
السعرات
السعرات ما هي ما هي زي بعض مثال زيت
الزيتون والزيوت المهدرجه
الجزء
زيت الزيتون ملعقه منه في 120 سعره تقريبا
ملعقه من الزيت الثاني
120 سعره
اذا اخذت الاثنين بنفس الكميه
وزنك راح يزيد
نعم
فالجسم ما يفرق صحي ولا مو صحي لكن فين
الفرق
الزيوت المهدرجه
ترفع من نسبه حدوث الجلطات تسبب لك جلطات
[موسيقى]
بينما هذا لا وزنك حيزيد بس ما راح تكون
معرض للجلطه لكن ان وزنك زاد فوق الحد
الطبيعي
فالسمنه بحد ذاتها
تعرضك للجلطات والامراض الاخرى
فشفت اللفه حق زيت الزيتون
وهذه على اي شيء ثاني
فلما تاخذ فانت كنت تقول مثلا في السناكات
تصير هي المشكله المكسرات
زي هذه لما تاخذ مثلا
يعني
هنا الفرق البطاطس يعني قطع منه اذا كانت
مثلا مقليه
ما تتخيل كميه السعرات اللي موجوده في كيس
الشيبس الواحد تمام وعيب الشيبس انه اذا
اكلت في العاده ما راح توقف صحيح
تقول ابغى اشتري كيس كبير
حاخد جزء وخليني اقفل عشان اكمل بعدين ولا
احد يقفله نخلص في نفس الجلسه هذا لوحده
ممكن يتجاوز الالف سعره
بينما مثلا
المكسرات لا حتطول الين توصل هذا الرقم
فهنا الفرق في نوع الطعام لما نيجي للنظام
اللي قلنا لازم تاكل الاكل بصورته
الكامله
فالصوره الكامله الهدف منها انه اذا اكلت
راح تشبع وصعب تتجاوز
السعرات هذي فهنا الفرق في نوع الطعام
في العياده عندي وهذه ممكن يعني
نطلب من
المشاهدين او المستمعين اذا طبقوا هذا
الكلام وزنهم راح ينزل
بكل بساطه تمام
اغلب الناس اللي عندي في العياده وزنهم
بينزل من غير ما اتدخل في وجباتهم
الرئيسيه
رقم واحد المشروبات
المشروبات من اكثر الامور التي تساعد على
زياده الوزن عشان كذا انا احب اعطيها او
اشتغل عليها للناس اللي بيرفع وزنهم
ايوه فايش المشكله في المشروبات
ما في عمليه المضغ
وش نقص المشروبات
جميع المشروبات بشكل عام اي شيء ينشرب اي
شيء تحطه في كاش او تشربه مويه قهوه مويه
قهوه عصيرات مشروبات غازيه
عصيرات معلبه عصيرات طازجه مشروبات طاقه
كل هذه الامور نشتغل عليها ايش الحاجات
اللي نشتغل عليها القاعده اللي لازم توصل
اللي هي لا تشرب سعراتك
لا تشرب سعراتك ايش يعني لا تشرب سعراتك
خذ المشروبات
اللي فيها صفر سعره تقريبا زي المويه
الشاهي القهوه
هذه خذ راحتك فيها بالحد المسموح يعني ما
تتجاوز مثلا اربعه اكواب قهوه
بدون اي اضافات طبعا ايوه ايوه بدون اي
اضافات حليب مدري ايش
تخرج عن هذا المضبوط هذه الثلاثه
المشروبات امنه ما عندك اي مشكله
نجي للمستوى اللي بعده اللي هو ايش
مشروبات الغازيه هل نفضلها لا
طب هل في نوع معين نفضله ايوه المشروبات
الغازيه الدايت
صفر سعره
دايتو للزيروتين
وهي على حسب الشركه في نفس الشركه عندهم
دايتو زيرو بس هي هي اللي يفرق التركيبه
نفسها
بس انه التركيب اللي هو حق السكر نوع
الحلى النكهه اقوى النكهه خف
فهمت فهذا افضل من طبعا
طبعا هذا افضل
بس كله سيء
طيب كيف نقول سيء مقارنه بايش
اذا جينا نستخدم العصيرات
يعني انا جاني ناس في العياده والله ابشرك
الحمد لله بطلنا المشروبات الغازيه ممتاز
طب ايش تشرب
طيب عصيرات اوكي زي ايش خلينا نتكلم على
البرتقال خف عصير ممكن
طيب عصير برتقال عشان تسويه كم برتقاله
كبست
يعني اذا دخلت محل العصير حتشوف او انا
سالت واحد حتى عنده محل عصيرات بيقول اقل
شيء ثلاثه ونص اربع برتقالات
فانت اذا شربت الكوب حرفيا
كانك اكلت اربع برتقالات طبعا اسالك سؤال
هل في جلسه واحده تقدر تاكل اربعه
برتقالات يعني صعب صعب لو انا جوعان لوحه
تسويها يمكن مره واحده وخلاص يعني
لمده يمكن ثلاثه اشهر
فالفكره انه العصيرات تخليك تاكل او تشرب
كميه انت ما انت عامل حسابها اساسا
عشان يطلع من موضوع مشروبات الغازيه
البرتقاله الواحده تقريبا من اربعين لستين
سعره خليه خليها خمسين متوسطه بس عشان
نقدر نحسب اربعه برتقالات
خمسين سعره 200 سعره الكوب صار
مشروب الغازي
غالبا ما يتجاوز 150 سعره
فهنا ايش معناته
ان البرتقال ايوه اكثر ضررا من المشروب
الغازي اكثر ضررا لزياده لزياده الوزن هنا
نكون دقيقين في الكلام زياده الوزن الجسم
قلنا القاعده الاولى ما يفرق صحي ما هو
صحي
كله محسوب
لكن فين مشكله هل معناته انا افضل المشروب
الغازي على ده لا
طب فين المشكله المشروب الغازي ضرروا على
جانبين الاول قلنا الوزن وهذه اللي هي لها
علاقه بالسكر والامور هذه كلها الجانب
الثاني اللي هو موضوع الهشاشه
يؤثر على امتصاص امور كثيره
فهنا انا ما افضله
على هذا اذا الاثنين نفس السعره اقول لك
لا خذ هذا واذا تتجنب الاثنين احسن طب هل
فعلا
مساله انه الاسيرات
لما يصير
البرتقاله على شكل عصير نتفقد كل
الفوائد الفوائد وما يبقى منها الا الطعم
والسكر هذه فيها تفاصيل كثيره لكن اختصار
الشيء اللي يهمني انا في موضوع الوزن انه
خسر الالياف
وانا ليش الالياف تهمني عشان تساعد على
الشبع
انا اكثر شيء يهمني والشخص وهو قاعد ينحف
انه يكون شبعان طوال الفتره مشكله الناس
لما يجوا يفكروا بينحفوا الحرمان القسوه
ضغط كانه بيعاقب نفسه هو لا نزول الوزن
يعني لازم تستمتع في الرحله ما يكون في
ضغط نفسي عليك لانه
ان دخلت في ضغط نفسي هذا اول شيء راح
يخليك تنتكس وترجع لعاداتك القديمه فهي ما
هي مساله نظام غذائي هي مساله تغيير
سلوكيات وتغيير نمط الحياه بشكل عام
طيب دحين مثلا الاشياء اللي كنت تقول انت
مشيت في المشروبات كنت تقول المشروباتي
اهم شيء
انت تشتغل على
ينقص وزنه
قلنا كل الاشياء مرينا بالغازيه في
العصيرات
فالحين عصيرات يعني خطا مو بصحيه بالنسبه
للناس
هل في شيء ثاني
يصير كذا نلخصه باختصار المشروبات المفضله
شاهي قهوه
انا انا اجيك على
المشروب وكيف نحل المشكله عشان نخلي
المشروب باقل الاضرار نتكلم عليها حلو
المويه الشاهي القهوه يجي بعدها المشروبات
اللي هي الدايت او اللي هي تستخدم فيها
المحليات الصناعيه
وضحنا انه البيبسي او المشروب الغازي
المشروب الغازي الدايتنقص
المشروب الغازي الدايت
[ضحك]
خذلك
طيب نكمل
المشروب الغازي الدايت
افضل من
عصير الطازج ولكن ما زال في ضرر اللي هو
الهشاشه فما المفترض انه نزيد في الكميه
لكن لما نيجي نقيس الايجابيات والسلبيات
فانا عندي
سلبيات
انه الشخص يكون في سمنه
اكبر من اني اخليه اخد علبه بيبسي
تطلع
مشكله هذه موضوعة اللي احنا اعلانات لا
عادي يعني
ما بحدد شركه يعني كلها شركتين
يعني
هذه الشركتين كويس
انه في عندهم
بس في شركات ثانيه لا وهذي مسببه لي مشكله
انا
بس يعني
حمضيات والحمضيات
الحين
العصير
طبعا انا ودي افصل عصير بس اذا تبغى تكمل
في المقطوع فانا بقول اللي هو ضرر السمنه
الزائده او السمنه المفرطه او الوزن
الزائد اكبر من اني اخليه مثلا يشرب مشروب
الغازي تمام
يجي بعدها مشروبات الطاقه
موجوده
انواع منها دايت كلها تقريبا ما عدا
الجديده اللي هو طلعت هذا شيء ثاني اغلب
المشروبات المشروبات الطاقه الموجوده في
منها البديل هذا الافضل
يعني الافضل في السيء نعم مضبوط مضبوط
في طازج اللي
كل الفواكه عباره عن سكر اللي هي مصدر
الكربوهيدرات
واخص
تمر
هذا من اهم الاسباب ما قلت لك في نصائح
معينه حنقولها كل
الناس التطبقوها ينزل اهم شيء التمر
يعني لا
ما يتجاوزوا ثلاثه في اليوم ثلاث حبات ما
يتجاوزوها
مؤتمر السمنه الاول اللي صار في اعتقد
السعوديه
جابوا كذا معلومه ملفته بيقول لك الشخص
اللي يتجاوز ثمانيه تمرات في اليوم
تقريبا سنويا وزنهم بيزيد يمكن فوق سته
كيلو
اللي يتجاوز هذا العدد
من التمر فقط ولا لان سلوكه سيء
بغض النظر
يعني احنا لما نيجي نقول التمر نيجي
للقاعده الاولى اللي هي ايش
الاطعمه بحد ذاتها ما فيها مشكله هي
المشكله في الباكج كامل اللي بيجي مع هذه
العاده
فهمت يعني انا لما اجي اقول التمر طب هذه
المعلومه اللي ذكرت
يعني علميا او نظريا اي منطقيه ايش دخل
التميمي لو انا ما اكل غير ثمانيه تمرات
في اليوم وزني راح يزيد سته كيلو مقارنه
بالشخص اللي كبسه كل يوم لا
بس هي المشكله انت يعني هذه لفته تنظر لها
انه ايش السلوكيات اللي بتطلع معها هؤلاء
الافرنت
التمر بياكلوا مع ايش هل لوحده ولا ما
قشطه وطحينه
ما مكسرات في في يعني هذا اللي يفرق بين
او هذا يوضح الفرق بين مسبب وبين مرتبط مش
مشكله التمر
مرتفع بالسكريات
وسهل انك تزيد فيه اي شيء سهل انك تزيد
فيه
هذا لازم الواحد ينتبه له فيحط كميه
يبغاها قبل لا يحضرها يا سلام هذه من
النصائح اللي احنا بنقولها او اللي انا
اقولها شخصيا انه لا تحط صحن تمر قدامك لو
حطيت انت قاعد تعذب نفسك
تعذب نفسك في ايش
لما اجي اعطي لك نصيحه اقول لك لا تزيد عن
ثلاثه تمرات حتى اخذ ثلاثه حبات طيب الصحن
اللي قدامك ايش حتسوي فيه
لا حيقدر يتفرج ولا حيقدر يتكلم مع الناس
يعني صحيح بس انه احيانا انت تحتاج ان
يمديني احطه ولا يمديني احط شوكولاته فهمت
تحتاج على الطاوله بعض السناكات والاشياء
الخفيفه فهذا صحي
[موسيقى]
دينيا
محبب
وفي العادات موجود ومع القهوه
فاهم علي يعني دينيا
ايش الدينين في الموضوع انه تاكل
ثلاثه الى سبع حبات حلو ثلاث الى سبع حبات
لما نيجي نتكلم ثلاثه الى سبعه حبات خلينا
نتكلم على سبعه لانه اغلب اللي بيزودوا في
العدد بيستخدموا رقم سبعه هو قريب من
الدراسه اللي قلنا عليها
سبعه في هذاك الزمن
تعتبر وجبه
ما كان فيها ما كان في ثلاجات
نواشف
اكل مجفف ان وجد
الان السبعه تمرات هذه متى بتاكله
ما تحسب يعني اذا حتعامل لي السبعه تمرات
كفطور
ورايح تكمل يومك ما عندي مشكله
بس توك متغدي
بعدين تنزل القهوه تنزل السبعه تمرات هنا
مشكله
شفت هذه النصائح اللي احنا جالسين نقولها
هي اللي تفتح باب
القارئ او المتلقي بشكل عامل طب ايش
بقيتوه انا ناكل
كل شيء بتقوله ممنوع
الال فواكه ممنوع التمر ممنوع المعرفه
ممنوع
فما في شيء ممنوع
تقريبا الا شي واحد
الزيوت المهدرجه
عادي
السكر له حد الامور هذه لها حد الزيوت
المهدرجه لحد حقها جدا يعني صغير
وش اللي منعت وزاره الصحه قبل كم سنه اي
في المنتجات اللي هي زي حق المطاعم وكذا
غيروا الزيت
لكن ما زال يعني ان الشخص ممكن يتعرض لها
بكثره القلي
بشكل عام
انتوا بتتكلموا مثلا طب ممكن ما هو هنا
يعني
بس هي الفكره انه هذا هو الشيء الوحيد
اللي
فاذا هذه هي المشكله الوحيده على الارجح
التعرض لك هذا هو
ايوه لكن ما زال هذا هو الشيء الوحيد اللي
نقدر نقول عليه
خطر الحاجات الثانيه مي خطر لكن لازم تعرف
توازن
الموازنه هي الاساس تبي تاكل تمر بالعافيه
عليك انا كل اللي دخل وعندي في العياده
تنتهي الجلسه بضحك وسواليف انه لا لا مو
من جدك يعني يجيني شخص مثلا يقول لي ابغى
نوع الشوكولاته معين انا اكل يوميا
تكفى لا تغير اللي هو اقول له ممتاز طب
جربت الاسكريم منه
نفس النوع بس خذ الايس كريم احسن لانه
ينصدم ليش انا اخترت الايس كريم عشان
فهمت فانا تفتكر ايش اول كلمه قلت لك هي
ايش افضل نظام غذائي هو النظام الغذائي
اللي انت تقدر تستمر عليه فانا ما حاجي
اعطي لك جدول جاهز اقول لك تفضل تطبق
وارجع لي لا انا لازم افهم انت كيف اسلوب
حياتك وبناء عليه اطلعك باقل الاضرار
الممكنه
لكن مستقبلا انا متاكد انه انت راح تغير
من سلوكك لما تبدا تشوف النتائج على نفسك
فهذا هو فائده تغيير النمط الصحي وبناء
العادات انا قاعد ابني لك عاده الحجر
الاساس الحجر الاساس
ان بنيت لك هذه العاده راح تتكون عادات
عليها بشكل تلقائي ففي ناس كذا لما نسمع
ايش اسلوب حياته
اقول له يعني اشيل اللي ناقصك انك بس تبدا
تتمرن لا بس انا جاي ابغى اغير اكله
واللي ما تحتاج لا كيف ما غيرك لي
جلسه تاخذ نص ساعه واربعين دقيقه عشان
اوصل له المعلومات ولما وصل المعلومات مو
شرط انه يقتنع
بس اعطيني فرصه شوف النتيجه اللي انا بقول
لك عليها
يروح يتمرن يرجع اساله نفس الاسئله اللي
سالته هي في البدايه
ايش الاقي عمل صح انه اتمرن الاقي لوحده
هو غير في اكله
والله قللته ما اعرف والله عملت كذا
مو لازم كل الناس اقول له غير غير لانه
انا زي ما قلت لك مشكله اغلب المجتمع
السناكات
المفرحات
هل العصيرات
تمر المكسرات
صبت الزيت
الناس اللي يحبوا ياكلوا فول
ويغرق الفول زيت من فوق يقول لك انا لو ما
شفت اللمعه هذا الكلام كله انا بقوله
بلسان
لو ما شفت اللمعه ما ارتاح لازم يشوف
حمص ولا فول بدون زيت يعني اخدمك حط
وزن الكميه يفرقه اول شيء زيت ولا
اوكي فالحين يعني نتكلم بشكل عام ومره ذاك
الحين
في اوقات مره كثيره
اكل الفول
بدون زيت بدون تميس
لا تاكل
اللي انا بوصل لك اياه هذا مصدر بروتين
انا حاسب ايش الشيء اللي ابغى اجتهد فول
يا اخي اجتهد فولو بس انا اكلت يعني اغلب
احتياجي في هذا اليوم خلاص مشتهي
الفولت مشكله
عادي هو في النهايه زي الخبز
السعرات زايده في حسب
يعني اذا حاسب
سعراتك مره لا تخاف كل اللي تبغاه يعني
انا قبل ما اتزوج
كلها يقول انت فرحان بوزنك اتزوج
وحنشوف ايش حيصير فيك عدت السنه الاولى
عدت السنه الثالثه الثانيه الثالثه
وزني زي ما هو بالعكس
زوجتي اتعدت مني ههه
فهي الفكره اذا انت فاهم
ايش بتعمل
حتحس انه حياتك اسهل ومريحه جدا ما احس
بحرمان عمري ما احس بحرمان عمري ما يجيني
توتر وقلق
تجاه الاكل مش هاكل ايش ما حاكل طالما انا
مخطط يعني صارت عاده عندي انه لما اصحى او
حتى من اليوم اللي قبل انا عارف ايش حفطر
ايش حتغدني حلو فخلاص ماشي
برجعك للحين العصيرات نرجع
للمشروبات غطيناها يعني اذا الان باقي
نقطه ما غطيناها اللي انت سالت عليها اللي
هو اضافه السكر طيب المشروب على الشاهي
اللي هي المحليات الصناعيه
اللي هي كاني خليت
الفكره نفس المشروبات الغازيه
معها المحليات طعم طعمها خايس بس اذا
تجاوزنا يعني
درجه ما احب الشاهي
[موسيقى]
الدكتور
ان المحليات صحيح ان ما فيها ضرر السكر
لكن تلعب البكتيريا في المعده
طيب نروح
نتكلم اول شيء على النقطه الاولى اللي هي
ايش
هل هي امنه ولا ما هي امنه هي امنه وهيئه
الغذاء والدواء كاتبه بالصريح امنه وحاطين
الحد اليومي من الاستخدام
السكر اتوقع كيف الحد اليومي ممتاز هنا
رجعتني النقطه اللي هي ايش تقول طعمها
خايس
ايش علاقه طعم الخايس بكم الحد طب هو كم
نوع فيه
انت جربت ايش الانواع انت يمكن جربت نوعين
طيب في باقي اربعه خمسه ثانيه غيرها فهمت
في ناس مثلا ما يحبوا المحلي الفلاني
جربوا هذا قالوا ما كانه صناعي نفس السكر
وسبحان الله اللي جربوا عجبهم ذا ما عجبهم
الثاني
فهي الفكره
جرب ممتاز قبل ما نحط عليها اكس تماما من
ناحيه الطعم نجرب جرب الانواع الثانيه انا
سبتك خلاص وقت نقول انه لا فلان ما يناسبك
نيجي لموضوع البكتيريا
اللي هي النافعه الموجوده في الجسم
لها علاقه بس يعني بشكل عام اذا اكلك
متكامل ما تخاف من هذه الناحيه
لانه انت اصلا بتجيبها من فين من الاكل
اللي هو المتوازن
من بعض انواع الخضروات من اللبن مثلا
الزبادي الامور هذه كلها
فالشيء البسيط هذا اللي دخل مو هو اللي
راح يغير لك جسمك بالكامل وهذا الضرر اقل
من ضرر السكر
بكثير بمراحل
بمراحل انا تبع ما بقيس الضرر بقيسه من
ناحيه ايش الوزن
[موسيقى]
طيب لما اجي مثلا اطالع في المراجعين في
العياده
وادخل على ملفهم اشوفه الاوزان من يوم ما
دخل مثلا من 2014
الى اليوم لما طالع في الوزن بيزيد في
السنه اثنين كيلو اثنين كيلو اثنين كيلو
فهنا المشكله
ما هي في وجبات الرئيسيه هنا المشكله في
الحاجات الزياده زي الثمانيه تمرات
فاول ما اصلحها
تلقائيا الزياره اللي بعدها وزن نازل وزن
نازل وزن نازل اقول له خلاص شكرا احنا
نجحنا مبسوط مبسوط راضي راضي يستمر هذا
اللي نبغى
طيب بالنسبه للسكر والمحليات كم
المعدل الطبيعي اليوم
ماني فاكره الارقام بالضبط بس السكر
اذا يعني ما خانتني الذاكره للرجال اعتقد
ثمانيه ملاعق للنساء سته ملاعق هذه من
السكر الابيض
المحليات لها يعني ارقام مختلفه كذا في
لها جد هذا على مده اليوم على كل الاصناف
اللي تاخذه اليوم كامل طبعا في يعني مصادر
سكر مره كثير في يومك ما نقدر نتحكم فيها
نهائيا يعني انا جيت كلمتك على السكر اللي
انت بتضيفه طيب في امور ثانيه انت بتاكلها
انت مو ضايفه وهو جاهز اصلا صلصه بالذات
الصوصات يعني
الخبز خبز
بس طالع من ورا دقيقه سكر ففي امور كثيره
يعني ما حاجي انا اعقد لك حياتك تلبس
العصير اذا برجعك عليه يعني خصوصا هذه
اللي في البقالات كلهم يعني نادرا تلقى
شركه تضيف عليها سكر ما في سكر مضاف يعني
اكتبوا لك ما في سكر بس هو اصلا يعني
ما يفرق سكر كذا ولا كذا في
تجربه
عملها
يسموها ايش اسم الكيك
[موسيقى]
هذا كان
واحد يشتغل في مختبر
كل اللي حوله
هذا وانت فاهم وتاكل لنا هذه هذا وانت ما
اعرفه
عدمه فعمل تجربه
اظن او حاجه زي كذا
نزل وزنه
وهو فقط ياكل
ما اكل اي شيء ثاني نظام الغذاء عباره عن
المفاجئ في الموضوع
انه لما وزن نزل حتى تحاليل واتحسنت
وهو بياكل شيء اصلا يعني ما هو متعارف
عليه انه صحي
فهذا اشي يخلينا نلتفت قديش خطر لما يكون
وزنك زايد
ما حقارن الخطر هذا بخطر انه هذا شيء سيء
فهمت فلا خذ
المشروب مثلا الدايت بس انحف هذا الاساس
عندي فالمخاطر الصحيه من السمنه اكثر من
خطر الصحيح يجيك من
مشروب مضبوط
مضبوط طيب اذا اضفت غير السكر
على المشروبات الاكل يعني
بتخيل مثلا العسل
اي نوع الدبس
علي بن علي
هي هي ما في فرق ابدا السكر هو سكر هي
يعني بس عشان
مو ضرر احنا بنتكلم يعني
كسعرات وزياده وزن هي نفس بعض يعني انا ما
ابغى استخدم الفاظ قويه
في غير مكانها ضرر كلمه قويه فهمت
بس انه لها نفس التاثير نفس التاثير
عشان يعني لما احنا نتكلم سكر بيكون حتى
يمكن المحليات احسن من العسل على كذا اذا
بتحطه على
ومتى تشوف يعني يعني مشدد على مين في هذه
الحالات الاشخاص اللي عندهم السكري
الشخص الطبيعي يقدر ياخذ يعني في مرونه
اكبر بينما الشخص اللي عنده السكري
ملعقه عسل
ترفع سكر فوق يعني حتى وهو طبيعي وحد يعني
ما الجسم ما يفرق خلاص هذه كيمياء كيمياء
وفيزياء
يمتص الجهاز الهضمي كله يطلع في الدم طلع
في الدم خلاص يبان الارتفاع يعني حتى في
واحد في قناه في يوتيوب
واحد
ما هو عربي بس بينزل كذا كل ما ياكل حاجه
يحلل يوريهم شوفوا كم الارقام فعمل تجربه
تضحك يعني
قارن بين الموز وشوكولاته معينه
جاب الموز انه رفع السكر اكثر من
الشوكولاته ليه لانه بس بكل بساطه كميه
السكر في هذه الشوكولاته اقل من الموز
فالارتفاعات هذه
يعني
ما الجسم ما يفرق صحي ولا مو صحي لكن
الناس
اي شيء صحي سوت وهذا غلط اي شيء طبيعي اي
شيء طبيعي او اي شيء حتى معروف انه صحي
زود فيه العسل يقول لك العسل اوف يعني
بالذات
المراجعين
الجنوبيين امي حتزعل عليك بس
كملنا
اصلي
ولا ملعقه صب
[ضحك]
شايف فهذه لا حرام يعني تفتكر لما تكلمنا
عن الفول الفول الصحن المسكين الغلبان هذا
السعرات اللي فيه
ما تتجاوز 90 سعره اللي هي الميه جرام
تقريبا 90 سعره ملعقه الزيت في المثال
اللي قلناه
120 سعره فانت تخيل الفول هذا
سعراته اقل من ملعقه الزيت ما في زيت دايت
بس
هذا الشيء شفت لما يقولوا اول
متعافين
يشربوا السمن وما يصير لهم شيء صحيح ممتاز
هذا على اول لانه في نشاط اكثر في حركه
والاكل اقل اصلا ما كان في كل الامور
المصنعه هذه فتلقاه يقدر ياكل وجبه الفول
بالزيت لانه هذه اصلا يعني من فين جات انا
هذه العاده من هذاك الوقت من هذا الزمن من
هذا الجيل
ياكل الفول مثلا الصباح
يكد يطلع النخل وينزل الين المغرب
[موسيقى]
هل ما زالوا متعافين لا
هم هذول اللي بيجون العياده الان
ليش
اتغيرت حياته بس ما غير اكله فهذه الوجبه
او هذه الطريقه ما هي مناسبه لهذا الزمن
الان
فبكل بساطه انا لازم يعني اخلي الشيء هذا
مناسب لهذا الزمن بس تقدر تاكل
الفول مثلا بالزيت بس وازن الوجبات اللي
بعد فهي مساله موازنه فقط
الحين المشروبات اتوقع كذا قفلنا اغلبها
بس وش اثرها اجمالا ليش تقول اني انا
اشيلها ولا ازيدها في زياده الوزن
لانه ما يقدر يحسب ولا يتوقع انها ما تشبع
ولا انها ما تشبع وسهل الواحد يزيد فيها
وما تقدر يعني ما انت متخيل حجمها يعني
مشروبات من المحلات القهاوي
بتلقى في المشروب قريب 600 سعره 600 سعره
هذه
600 سعره يعني كانك اخذت مثلا اثنين فروج
صغير بس يعني يعني هذا المشروب اللي انت
شربته اللي الان حتشربه عشان تاكل او تاخذ
معاه شيء انت حرفيا اذا هذي كميه السعرات
هذه حطيتها في وجبه ما راح تقدر تاكل شي
بعدها اتوقع البيج معك
شيء زي كذا يعني
مثلا
يعني احسن من
الفكره حسبت السعره خلاص انا عارف بس هل
تاخذ البيج ماكله لوحده
[ضحك]
لا لا لا خليك خليك
قديش كميه الكاتشب
بس
طيب انت
فهمت وبعدها يعني مثلا
هي هنا الفكره انت طالع في البكج كامل هل
600 سعر هذه اللي انت قلتها
حتشبعك ولا لا
600 سعره لو انا اعمل لك هي مثلا طبخ
البيت اكل كامل
راح تشبعك مره فهمت
يعني مثلا بعد المطاعم
معروف انه لازم يجي معها الصوصات
الصوص الواحد العلبه الصغيره حتتفاجئ انها
صحي طيب
شفت كيف يسوي
لا شفت كيف
ما لازم
يعني عندي التصور انه سيء بس الثوم والثوم
بايش بيعملوا
لازم
لازم لما تدخل كذا انه في امور
ما بنلتفت لها مع ذلك برضو انا اكل الثوم
واكل الامور هذه كلها بس اذا تبغى تحسب كم
سعره حراريه بيضيف عليها تبدا تحسب
تدري اول مره
ما عمره جاء في بالي ان الثوم ممكن يكون
والله كذا ما في حبات مستحيل يقول لك
فهمت ايه هنا الفكره
في جانب مره مهم طالما احنا بنتكلم عن
الوزن والامور هذه كلها
ليش الوزن يزيد
ايش يعني الوزن عباره عن ايش ليش الحرق
تسمع يقول لك انا حرقي قليل
انا اكل وجبه واحده اقسم بالله ما اكل غير
هذه الوجبه
وزني ما ينزل
هذه يوضح لك اهميه الحساب السعرات حساب
السعرات
يعني
هو الاساس في كل شيء
حساب السعرات هو الاساس لكن هل لازم اطبقه
لا
لما اجي اقول فلان الحرق عنده قليل ايش
يعني حرق ايش يعني اي
للميت
الان جسمنا الان انت شخص موجود قدام عباره
عن
كتله ومخزن من الطاقه وانا مخزن من الطاقه
ما ابغى الموضوع يصير علمي لكن
تخيل شخصين احجامهم مختلفه واحد كبير واحد
شويه صغير
مين اللي عنده طاقه اكبر بس كذا بالمثال
اللي انا قلته الان الاكبر الحجم اكبر
تمام
خلينا ناخذ هذول الشخصين في الصحراء
نرميهم بدون اكل
مين اللي راح يعيش
اكثر من اللي راح يموت اول
الاكبر بايش اللي اكبر بايش ليش
عشان مخزن الطاقه هذا اكبر فالجسم بياخد
من نفسه في الفتره اللي ما بياكل
فنيجي لموضوع الطاقه وحركه الطاقه والامور
هذه كلها
كيف وزنك ينزل وكيف وزنك يزيد
مثال انا اعطيتك الان قلت لك خذ هذه الفين
ريال يوميا لازم تصرف 2000 ريال اي شيء
زائد حطه في جيبك ولا تطلعه طيب اليوم
اعطيتك 2000 صرفت 2000 باقي معك شي لا
بكره اعطيتك اليوم اللي بعده اعطيتك 2500
قاعدتنا ما تصرف غير الفين
كم باقي معك
يوميا قاعد اعطيك 2500 ايش حيصير في جيبك
نفخ نفس الشيء جسم الانسان
جسمك يوميا يصرف
عدد معين من السعرات
ان اكلت اكثر من هذا العدد
جسمك راح يخزن
فبدال ما نتكلم عن المال احنا بنتكلم عن
السعرات
فالشحوم هذه الموجوده هي عباره عن فائده
الطاقه الموجود في هذا الشخص
نيجي لنقطه اللي هي احنا قلنا الفائض طيب
كيف ينحف
نفس المثال نرجع عشان نطلع من المواضيع
اعطيتك
1500 1500 يا سلام جبتها من الاخر 1500
وقلت لك لازم تصرف 2000 ريال انت صرفت
1500 باقي له 500 فين حتجيبها من جيبك حط
طلعها وجابك حيه صغار حيصغر خلص اللي في
جيبك حتبدا تتسلف تسرق اي شيء الجسم هيبدا
يصغر ويكش فهمتني فهذه بكل بساطه هي
كيف الواحد يزيد وزنه كيف الواحد ينحف
وهذه هي القاعده اللي مستحيل اي شخص
متعلم
متخصص
ينتقد هذا
ينتقد السعرات
فيه
طيب ولا
الانسولين والهرمونات طيب
لما نيجي نتكلم مين هم اكثر ناس يحاربوا
السعرات يقول لك هي خرافه تلقاهم ناس
غالبا متبعين اللي هي الانظمه
اللي هي
قليله شو اسمه الكربوهيدرات او قليه
السكريات فايش ايش الحجه حقتهم اللي بيقول
لك انه هذا نظام سيء
الحجه انه
بيقول لك اذا انت اكلت سكريات
اول ما توصل الدم حيرتفع الانسولين
الانسولين دوره ينزل السكر طيب كيف ينزل
السكر بامور كثيره من ضمنها انه يحول
السكر الى دهون
هذا كلامهم وهو صحيح
فالسكر الانسولين حولوا الى دهون طيب اذا
امتنعنا من السكر
هل معناته عمره ما راح تتحول دهون في
جسمنا
هم ايش يقولوا
كل اي شيء في
الدهون بروتين واقطع من السكر مهما تاكل
وزنك ما راح يزيد
ليل انه الانسولين ما ارتفع بالتالي جسمك
ما راح يحول هذه الدهون فيجي يقول لك
معناته ايش الهرمونات
هي الاساس في الوزن ما هي السعرات
اذا زادت هذه العمليه اللي هي زياده السكر
والانسولين زياده السكر والانسولين حبدا
الجسم يتشبع بالسكر في الدم ويصير ما عنده
القدره انه يخفي هذا السكر لانه هو ليش
يحوله لانه بينزل فصار زي ما تقول ايه كل
العمليات مكتفيه وصار فيه فائض في السكر
والدم اتشبع بالتالي كل ما الجسم يبي
يستخدم سكر كل المناطق مقفله يقول لك ما
اقدر ليه مشغول الان
قاعد احول كميه السكر هذه وماني قادر
استخدمها خلاص فل مشبع يقول لك ايه مقاومه
الانسولين طيب ايش الجسم يترجم هذا بيصير
داخل الجسم طيب خارج الجسم ايش الجسم
يترجمه جوع انه ما في طاقه الجسم معبى
طاقه في الدم فل واس ما هو قادر يستخدمها
ما يفهم
يقول لك جوع كل كل
الكلام هذا اللي انا بقوله انت حتشوفوا
منطقي
صحيح ايوه طيب ايوه خلاص انا لازم
امتنع اقلل من السكريات عشان لا يصير هذا
الموضوع هذي اللي هي المدرسه يسموها سي اي
ام اللي هي كربوهيدرات اللي هو نموذج
الكربوهيدرات والانسولين المدرسه الاساسيه
اللي اسمها اللي هي كالوريز ان كالوريز
اوت السعرات الداخله والسعرات الخارجه
فحرب بين المدرستين هذه
كلام المدرسه
بيشرحوا الموضوع بشكل احلى لانه في تفاصيل
وحكايه وتحس الكلام جدا جميل فيجب يعني في
النهايه لخص لك الموضوع ايش يقول لك
الهرمونات هي الاساس هي اللي تخليك تجيب
سعرات فصار المشكله مين جاء اول البيضه
ولا الدجاجه
كيف نرد عليهم
لما نيجي نقول البيض والدجاجه
هذا الشيء على جسم الانسان يختلف الموضوع
هل الشخص هذا طفل ولا رجل بالغ بيفرق يفرق
اذا قلنا نتكلم عن الهرمونات
فالشخص اللي عنده مشكله في الهرمونات مثلا
الطفل
حيتاثر نمو
يتاثر نمو فهذا معناته هل كلامهم صح انه
لسه ما نقدر نرد
يتاثر نمو انه ما راح يقدر يكبر ولا يقدر
يعني بشكل عام طيب خلينا نقول هرمونات
سليمه تماما اموره كلها كويسه لكن ما
اعطينا مغذيات كفايه هل رايحين مو ما راح
ينمو حيصير في مشاكل زي ما بيصير في بعض
المجاعات
فهنا يورينا انه السعرات هي الاساس في
النمو او عدم النمو
بغض النظر عن الحاله الهرمونيه الحاله
الهرمونيه هذه يعني شيء مرضي ما نقدر
نتحكم فيه لكن ان كل شيء سليم واعطيناه
هذا
الموضوع السعرات
الاطفال موضوع الهرمونات عندهم مهم جدا
نموهم على مستوى اللي هي
يسموها الكتله الصافيه نمو الاطفال يكون
على العظام على العضلات على حجم الاعضاء
بيكبر جسمه كامل بينما نمو البالغين على
مستوى الدهون
لان هذا نمو اكتمل ووقف الفائض فين حيروح
طاقه صغير لا
عشان كذا الصغار
ما ننصح انهم يعملوا انظمه غذائيه قاسيه
نهائيا
حتى لو كان وزنه زائد
تمام حتى لو كان وزنه زائد
فكر فيها خلينا نقول عمره 12 هل طول
واكتمل لا لسه
فاذا كان مثلا عريض
وانا ماسك وزنه خلينا نقول وزنه 80 مثلا
80 وصار قاعد يطول
من طول مثلا خلينا نقول 140 صار طوله 180
لكن واسمه وثمانين ممتاز شفت
فالاطفال لهم معامله ثانيه
[موسيقى]
شوف كيف وتزيد العقده النفسيه والطفل يبدا
ياكل ويفرق في الاكل بس يمكن لنا ايش
المشكله لان الطفل جالسي يطول ويزيد وزنها
يعني يوقف
وزن ويطول تنحل المشكله وليش وزن قاعد
يزيد سعرات
زايده عن الحد فانا الشخص
الاطفال او المراهقين خصوص على البنات
لانه
الدوره الشهريه عندهم تتاثر يعني بابسط
بابسط تاثير من برا
فهذول اللي يبان انه هل انت شديت او ما
شديت فلا ما نفضل انه اصلا احنا نكون
قاسيين معاهم كل بسعرات المحافظه لا هي
تصرف 500 ولا هي تزيد 500 خليك زي ما انت
خلينا نشوف النمو يكتمل خليه يكتمل وراح
ننزل ما يمنع انه ينزل نزول مره بسيط بس
ما هو النزول اللي يعني اخليه يلتزم في
برنامج قديش كبره يعني
تكلمنا عن السيارات كيف نقدر نضبطها
وانه في اكثر من نظام
اذا جينا للانظمه اللي جالس الناس يعني
تبغى تنهف عليها يعني في عندنا مثلا
الكيتو في عندنا الصيام المتقطع في ايش في
شيء ثاني اشياء المشهوره
النباتيه نقدر نحطها
كثيره مالها اول ولا اخر
مثل واحد يدخل وياخذ واحده من هذه الانظمه
علشان
في نظام غلط
مع الكل ونفسي اكون مع الكل لكن هذه قدرتي
لو احد قرا الكتاب ممكن
يقدر يغير سلوكه طبعا هو هذا الهدف
انا ليش اساسا كتبت الكتاب بدات الفكره من
بدايه جائحه كورونا
كنت بتعامل مع ناس انا دائما اصلا اهتمامي
موضوع الوزن يعني انا في النهايه طبيب
اسره
جزء صغير من طب الاسره اللي هو التحكم في
الوزن الامور هذه كلها فانا انا قاعد
اتكلم فيه هو في النهايه جانب صغير من
تخصص
فالناس اللي انا كنت بتابع معاهم قطعت
عنهم
ما اقدر اشوفهم ولا يقدر يشوفوني فهذا
الشيء اثر فيه ان انا زعلت يعني
انا لاي ظرف كان ماني موجود طبعا الكلام
هذا انا لسه ما خلصت مع الشخص بدات اكتب
الكتاب
والسبب الثاني
كنت اكتب تغريدات التغريدات
بتنزل في الاسفل بلاقي الاسئله بترجع
وبرجع اجاوب وارد فقلت لا خليني انا اعمل
هذا الكتاب
انزل فيه اغلب المعلومات الاساسيه بدون
فلسفه بدون تعقيد اي شخص يقرا هذا الكتاب
خصوصا الناس اللي لهم تجارب كثير سيئه
هم اللي راح يستفيدوا منه
[موسيقى]
انها صعب الواحد يلتزم فيها حتى لو كانت
الفتره يعني اتوقع لا لو كانت فتره عادي
يعني الكيتو اتوقع انهم دائما يقولون فتره
في ناس فتره في ناس يحبونوا عليه لا فتره
انا ما عندي مشكله كمرحله انتقاليه كنوع
تغيير كتجربه بالعكس لازم تجرب ما تدري
فين الاشياء اللي تستمتع فيها انا جربت
نظام النباتي بس كده واجرب يعني مره
استمتعت الاكل بالنسبه لي كان لذيذ لكن هل
قدرت تستمر لا صعب اجلس انا يعني في
السفره مع اهلي كلهم لا لا ما اقدر
ميه ميه يعني ميه حلوه اجتماعيا
وشكلت علي ضغط فوقفت
مرحله متقطع الصيام المتقطع الصيام
المتقطع هو ما هو نظام غذائي هو
جدول
لتوقيت الوجبات
فهو يساعدك انك ترتب يومك بس
طبعا طبعا بالذات بالذات للاشخاص اللي
اغلب اكلهم سناكات وداخل العمل
فانا لما اجي اجلس مع شخص واسمع انه هو
يوميا
يفطر فطورين وياخد سناكات في العمل اقترح
عليه الصيام بس ولا غير اي حاجه
وزنه يبدا ينزل
فشفت يعني لازم نلاقي فين الخلل واعطي له
الحل وينزل عليها مو كل الناس لازم كل
الناس لازم يطبقوا الصيام كل الناس لازم
يطبقوا الكيتو
ينفع لناس
يحبوا الاكل الحالي مره
اذا قدر يلتزم
فهذا تقريبا حياته راح تتغير تماما
اذا قدر طبعا الناس اللي يحبوا الحالي صعب
يتخلو عنه في يعني الحين المحليات الثاني
ليه لو تروح بعض المحلات تلقى عندهم ايس
كريم حتى اكيد
هنا مشكله في المسميات
يقول لك يقول لك صحي يقول لك وهي خاليه من
هذه الامور كلها
غذاء مرتفع البروتين
[موسيقى]
وهذه تكلمت فيها مع الدكتور ادم في تويتر
من فين جاءت تسميه مرتفع البروتين اذا كان
البروتين
يعني يادوب اتجاوز عشره يعني عشره جرام
بروتين خلاص مرتفع بغض النظر
ايش
السكر الدهون فخلاص اقول لك بروتين هيلثي
فالحليب
يعني في حليب الحين لا الحليب ده ممتاز
ممتاز جدا جدا جدا جدا
والزبادي نعم اليوناني
ممتاز جدا جدا جدا
لان القاعده اللي هي قلناها ايش كل ما
رفعت البروتين كل ما
زادت فتره الشبع فهذا الشيء يساعد انا
بالنسبه لي هذا افضل من العاده اي نعم
كل ما زودت البروتين كل ما هذا الشيء فادك
على المدى البعيد
فيه مره كنت اسمع الواحد فكان يقول اني
اغير النمط حياته انه صار ياكل
الوجبه الواحده
نظام المحارب المحارب دايت
وانه صممت بنظام مؤقت
وانه صار ياكل يعني
اقول لك كذا المحاربين زمان يتحرك وما
ادري وبعدين خلاص يا دوب يرجع ياكل الوجبه
هذه وخلاص ايش فكرتها امتنا عن الاكل
تماما وخصص وجبه واحده يقول لك اكل فيها
اللي ابغاه لو تلاحظ اللي اصلا عامله
النظام قراءه النظام حقنا
ما ياكل مثلا وجبات سريعه وكده كله اكل
بيت تقريبا الاكل هو قاعد يعمله بنفسه
واذا قلت احتياج الشخص الفين سعره مثلا بس
كذا مثال واغلب الناس يعني او او الرجال
حول هذا الرقم ترى مره صعب مره مره مره
مره صعب انك تاكل الالفين سعره
عشان كذا سمعت النظام انه تاكل قد ما تبغى
وهي حلوه انا طبقته بنفسي ولا كيف صرت
اقدر اكل دجاجه كامله
انا قاعد اجرب
صيام متقطع استخدمه كثير اذا بدات يعني
اتقروش بسبب الاكل ايش حفطر خلص وقف حارجع
البيت
اروح الدوام وانا صائم
او صيام متقطع اللي هو اشرب قهوه او مويه
واكمل الى اخر الدوام خلص الدواماتي عندي
غداء عشاء
بس هلا اضرار طيب هذا كثره الصيام عن
الاكل
لها اضرار
على السيدات
قلنا احنا الهرمونات والدوره الشهريه
تتاثر اذا كان في سوء تغذيه واذا استمرت
فتره طويله على الصيام تحديدا السيدات
لكن يعني في النهايه هذا هو اسلوب الحياه
الطبيعي انه ما يكون الاكل لحولك طول
الوقت
يعني اذا جينا نقول اللي هو صيام 16 ساعه
تقريبا
اقرب للحياه الطبيعيه تنام تصحى مو لازم
على طول الاكل حولك
تنجز شويه في يومك باين ترجع تتغدى او
مثلا تفطر بعدين نتغدى بعدين تتعشى كذا
حاجات خفايا اما سناكات اللي في النص تجي
هي المشكله هي هنا المشكله طيب في ناس
كثير تقول انه سالفه ثلاث وجبات انهم اصلا
في سلوك الانسان المفترض انه نكمل عليه
فالفطور والغداء والعشاء يعني هذه مجرد
خرافه
وعشاء الفقراء
اكل الملوك في العشاء
يعني لو عكسناها
بنومك حي يعني تنغل انه خطا غير انه انا
اقول لك شيء من هنا مضحك
الوجبه اللي انت تاكلها هذه ترى الجسم ما
يستخدم طاقتها الان
فهمت
ما اقدر احدد لك المده تقريبا يعني ايام
ساعات لا لا ساعات فانت لا تحس بالوجبه
اللي اكلتها الان هي اللي انت ماشي عليها
لا يعني زي رمضان مثلا انت صائم كيف شغال
وكيف بتسوي امورك كلها ما حد شغال ههه
ممكن
حد نفسك لا بس في ناس كثيرين في ناس
كثيرين
بيشتغلوا عادي ترى يعني اذا قد طبقت اللي
هو نظام الصيام المتقطع ترى حتلاقي
انتاجتك ساعدت اذا اذا يعني طبقته بفتره
معينه ولا انا ليش صرت احب اصلا الصيام
لاني شفت الفرق
شفت الفرق بين لما
يعني
فاطر وماكل وجبات معينه بكميه معينه كيف
انتاجيتي
وانا ماني ماكل شيء لانه انت ترى لما
بتاكل الجهاز الهضمي الدم كله ماشي فيه
تمام
وناس بعد الاكل يجيهم
يعني
اللي هو فطور الملوك والامور هذه كلها ومن
الحملات التسويقيه اصلا انه الفطور اهم
وجبه هذه كلها اللي هي من يعني الشركات
الامريكيه حق الكورن فليكس والامور هذه
كلها
يهمك انه مثلا اذا ما اكلت الفطور راح
تتعب ومعرفه هذه الفطور يخليك قوي ومعرفي
عشان تكمل يومك تروح عملك لكن ما هو شيء
اساس الفطور
بس اذا تحب الفطور بالعافيه عليك
فطور بس هو كتسميه
كمان من ضمن الامور جايه تسميات هذه
غداء العمل مثلا الغداء هذا اللي بيصير
يعني من يعني الحاجات اللي صارت التغيرات
اللي صارت في الناس اللي كانوا يشتغلوا في
مثلا المناجم والامور هذه كلها من باب
اني انا ارغب
في العمل في الفتره هذيك القاسيه
خذ فطور العمل ويدوب يحطوا لهم بطاطس ولا
ايش يحطونها
فمن هناك صارت اللي هي تطور موضوع غداء
العمل الى شيله غداء غداء العمل غدا
مرات كثيره انا ما قلت ترى فطور غدا عشاء
الوجبه الاولى الوجبه الثانيه الوجبه
الثالثه عشان ما احكم نفسي
فطور لازم وجبات معينه اتخيلها لما اجي
اقول لك فطور يقول لك عشا
اتغيرت تخيل فلا ما فرق كل اللي تبغاه في
اي وقت
طيب بس انت قلت
نقاش نبيل الان مرات في البدايه غير مهم
ابدا مرات تكون بتوقيت مهم مره حلو
ممكن نسيت اتوقع اليوم بدينا نتكلم على
الصيام انه وقت التوقيت انه بيكون مهم
للاكل توقيت
توقيت الصيام يعني انا فين حطيت موقع
الصيام في الوقت اللي مليان فيه اكل فهذه
الاهميه بس هل يفرق اذا صمت الصباح او صمت
المساء لا يعني مبدئيا نتفق انك
الدكتور الحلقه السابقه الدكتور احمد
بهمام مثلا فهو دكتور في النوم فكان اكثر
شيء بالنسبه للمزعج اللي هو الاكل قبل
النوم لان يعني يبدا يلخبط نومك وان النوم
مهم جدا واعتقد انه يمكن هنا حتى تتفق معي
قديش انه مهم على صحه على الوزن اذا ما
تنام زين يعني على الارجح انك ما راح تنحف
ايوه هو فاهم علي يعني الاكل المتاخر
اليوم باثر على
نومك اللي بياثر على وزنك فمهم التوقيت
طيب شفت التفاصيل هذه كلها اللي بنقولها
هي اللي بتخلي الناس انهم ما يلتزموا في
اي نظام
متى انام متى اكل متى ما اعرف
طيب هو توقيت الاكل له علاقه بالنوم صح
توقيت التمرين هل يؤثر على النوم صح
طب الشخص اللي ما عنده مشكله في النوم هل
حتفرق التفاصيل
يعني انا اكل قبل النوم مباشره ما عندي
مشكله انا مو كل يوم تجيني ايام فاهم
هل جوده النوم بتاثر ممكن لكن انا ما عندي
مشكله في النوم عشان ادخل في هذه التفاصيل
فبالنسبه لشخص
يعني ما عنده مثلا اي مشاكل غير الوزن
ما يفرق معايا توقيت الوجبه
عدد الوجبات
عندي اهم شيء
التزم عدد السعرات الطاقه الرصيد اللي
بيطلع بالنسبه للوزن كيف نخليها احلى
التزم بالسعرات
بالحاجات اللي تكلمنا عليها المتعارف
عليها اللي هي الصحيه يعني لا تلتزم بس
السعرات فاحنا قلنا السعرات ما هي وحده
اني اكل ميه سعره او 200 سعره من مصدر
مثلا اللحم
غير لما اكل 200 سعره مثلا من عصير لحن
يشبعني هذا ما راح يشبعني مع انه بنفس
السعره
لو جبنا شخصين واحد يعني
شخصين بشكل عام خلينا هذا بس ياكل لحم
يعني لمده يومين لحم لحم لحم لحم نفس هذا
السعرات هاد الفين سعره من اللحم هذا
الفين سعره من العصير
يعني يعني ما هي منطقيه بس ابغى اوصل لك
انه هذا راضي هذا غير راضي
مع انه الاثنين
تاثير الوزن واحد يعني اثنين هم يمتنو
مثلا بس هذا حيكون جيعان وطفشان وكل شويه
باله مشغول يلا متى متى العصير اللي بعده
ومتى العصير اللي بعده فهمت هذا لا مبسوط
عندنا
[ضحك]
شباب مره كبير
بس
على التوقيت ودي اعرف متى يبدا ينزل الوزن
يعني لما اذا غيرت نظام السيارات مثلا
والتزمت باي اليه معينه خصوصا اذا اني انا
انتهج نهج تغيير النمط مو بال مثلا
اقدر اشوف النتائج يعني متى اعرف اني انا
ماشي صح لانه يعني يمكن جسمي يختلف عن
جسمك
طيب نقول انت الان قررت انك تبغى تبدا
تغير النمط الصحي
اول فكره لازم تكون موجوده في بالك ان هي
رحله طويله ما هي سباق خلاص
فلازم تقيس وزنك بشكل اسبوعي
حتشوف تغير الوزن فخليني اقول انت الان
بتغير نمط الحياه من غير ما بتحسب من غير
اي حاله
غيرت امور بسيطه نهايه الاسبوع وزنك نزل
فانت نجحت هذه البساطه
هل ممكن انك تغير ويزيد
مو بالضروره الا اذا اخطات في شيء يعني
خليني اقول مثال دايما يتكرر
ملعقه فول سوداني مثلا
قلت يلا ابغى ادخل حاجات معروف انه كويسه
ملعقه فول سوداني
ملعقه غير
ملعقه
فهمت فالاخطاء الصغيره هذه اللي يقول لك
طب انا اكلت ملعقه واحده انا ماشي صح
الزيادات هذه اللي تصير هي اللي الناس ايش
يقول لك اغلب الناس
يعني
بيحسبوا او يعتقدوا انهم ماشيين صح
فقال الاسبوع الاول وزنك نزل الاسبوع
الثاني وزنك نزل الاسبوع الثالث
مو لازم تنزل
اربعه كيلو في شهر خلاص طالما وزنك بينزل
فاتاكد انه راح يستمر في النزول اليه ما
يوصل لحد الطبيعي لكن
هم قاعده
الرياضه ما تكلمنا عنها شيء
باهم جانب هو الجانب اللي ما هو موجود عند
الناس طيب
على التوقيت اللي هو
في ناس تقول انه تحرق اكثر في ناس ما تحرق
اكله علاقه هل فيه طبيعه الانسان في ناس
فعلا كذا في ناس كذا فتلقى ناس ما تمتنع
ابدا والناس ما تنحف ابدا
[موسيقى]
طيب الحرق شفت المثال اللي قلنا عليه
الصرف 1500 طيب والحجم اذا انت حجمك اكبر
راح يصرف اكثر طيب اثر فيات هذه اصلا فين
الجسم بيصرفها احنا عندنا
بالعاميه مره جسمنا فيه زي ثلاثه محركات
البنزين ينحرق في الثلاثه هذي
طيب
فلان حرق واكثر معناته واحد من المحركات
هذه شغال اكثر من الشخص الثاني بس كيف او
ايش هي اصلا محركات
في محركات تقريبا الكل يتساوى فيها اللي
هي ايش الاول شفت الاعضاء حق الجسم كامله
الم مع القلب مدري هذه تصرف طاقه يوميا
تمام هذا اول محرك
المحرك الثاني اللي هو النشاط الحركه لما
تيجي تحرك هذا يعني صرفيه اضافيه على
الحركه اللي صارت
والثالث اللي هو عمليه الهضم اللي قاعده
تصير كل ما تاكل هذه لها كذا شيء مخصص لها
طيب كل الناس زي بعض تقريبا حسب حجم الجسم
يعني يعني تناسب طردي في موضوع الاعضاء
الاشكاليه في موضوع الحركه
انت سؤالك مين يحرق مين ما يحرق الحركه
خليها على جنب ما لها علاقه
ليش
اذا انا خليني اقول وزني 70 وانت وزنك 70
معناته نفس الحجم ليش انا ممكن احرق اكثر
منك وانا ما عندي اللي هو مرض مثلا نشاط
الغده الدرقيه
في اهم عضو هو اللي مسؤول عن معدل الحرق
في جسم الانسان العضلات الكتله العضليه
حتى وانت ما بتتحرك انت الان جالس زي كذا
وانا جالس زي كذا وانا وانت نفس الوزن انت
عندك الكتله العضليه اكبر مني فجسمك طول
ما هو جالس بيستهلك طاقه اكثر
ليش لانها زي المصنع شغال شغاله تحرق
العضلات هي تقريبا الشيء الوحيد اللي نقدر
نتحكم فيه في تحسين معدل الحرق واي شخص
يقول انا جسمي حاسه الحرب عندي ضعيف
ممكن كلامه صح ممكن هو ما بياكل اصلا او
ممكن اكله سيء بس خليني اقول فرضا انه من
جد كلامه صح
نقيس الكتله العضليه نلقاها معدومه
اول ما اخليهم يتمرنوا
تمارين مقاومه اللي هي التمارين الاساسيه
التي تبني العضلات
وزن بده ينزل حيزيد في البدايه لانه هو
زاد عضلات البدايه ذي كم مدتها الزياده
قصدك
شهرين وزنك في زياد تقريبا
بعد شهرين تبدا يشوف النزول العجيب
هذه هي الحلقه المفقوده في نزول الوزن
والزياده هذه كم ممكن تكون كيلو على حسب
يعني مثلا النحاف جدا اللي يعني ما يعني
نحافه نحافه من جد
تصنيفها
كنحف مرضي اذا اتمرن حديد ممكن يزيد سبعه
ثمانيه كيلو من اول شهر
بينما الناس اللي عندهم سمنه بس حرقوا
قليل هو اصلا عنده كتله عضليه اصلا بس
تحتاج تحسن كتلته شويه اقل من الطبيعي
لحجمه فهذا لا يعني ممكن يزيد
ثلاثه كيلو بالكثير اللي نشري يصير انه
يدخل النادي
يقعد شهر وهو معدل اكله يعني يشتغل على
السعرات يعني
فهو جالس يعني
يجيك رمضان مثلا يخلص شهاده يلقى نفسه
وزنه زائد يبطل هذي واحده من الاسباب انا
يمكن لو اعرفكم المده اللي بعدها يخرج
ممكن يغير مو هي هذه التفاصيل اللي تحتاج
تعرفه انا لما اجي اقول لك روح اتمرن انا
لازم انبهك
زي اي دواء انا بعطيك هو لازم انبهك ايش
الاعراض الجانبيه اللي ممكن تشوفه عشان
لما تصير لك لا تنفجع لا تحسب انه في شيء
غلط لا هذا متوقع
اتمرن حديد اسمع وزنك راح يزيد لا تنفجر
طالع في المرايه وطالع في لبسك هذا اللي
يفرق ليش الحديد عامله معامله الذهب ايش
يعني
كتله قليله تعطيلك وزن كبير في الميزان
بينما الشحوم لا
كتله كبيره تعطيك رقم قليل في الميزان
عشان كذا لما يجي لك شخص يقول لك والله لي
شهرين اتمرن وزني زي ما هو زعلان طيب جسمك
تغير يقول ايوه تغير وملابسي ومن هنا طب
انت ليش زعلان عشان الميزان ما تغير طيب
ايش اللي صار هنا بالضبط
وزنه 80 نزل واحد كيلو دهون وزاد واحد
كيلو عضل
ايش صار في وزنه زي ما هو
فاحنا انا ايش قلت لك زيت ذهب الواحد كيلو
اللي زادها اصلا مو لاقيها فين
بينما الشحوم هذه الواحد كيلو اللي راحت
هي اللي فرقت ملابسه وحتى فيه الصور اللي
تبين لك
الواحد كيلو لان العضل والواحد كيلو مثلا
ايوه هذه الصور مثلا تبحث عنها مثلا
فهذه هذه يعني لوحدها تفرق يعني فؤاد كان
رياضه فقولي رياضه اهميتها وش نقصد في
الرياضه
للوزن هل
الكارديو ولا المقاومه يعني اي ايهما
طيب انت عشان تنحف لازم تسوي رياضه تسمع
الكلمه هذه طب ايش الرياضه هل هي صحيحه
لا لا لانه موضوع الوزن متعلق بالاكل
تماما الصرفيات
فابسط مثال الناس اللي عملوا تكميم
جالس ينحف نزول عجيب
وكثيرين ما بيعملوا رياضه غير المشكله ميه
في الميه حق الوزن تخص
المدخولات فاذا تبغى تنحف لكن اهم اولا
لكن
ما يعني ما ينفع بس نقول تبغى تنحف احنا
في النهايه هدفنا الصحه صح فلما اجي اعطي
نصيحه عامه زي الرياضه
طب الرياضه ايش نوعها
هل
المشي اليومي يعتبر رياضه هلا الاشغال
اليوميه تعتبر هذا لا ما تعتبر لا شفت
المحركات الثلاثه اللي انا قلتها انا قلت
لك بس الاول
المحرك الثاني اللي هو حق النشاط البدني
ينقسم قسمين نشاط بدني رياضي نشاط مدني
غير رياضي
اوكي الصدمه فين
النشاط البدني الرياضي يمثل تقريبا
5% من اللي انت بتحرقه في يومك كامل
اللي هو التركيز الناس كله فيه انا لازم
اسوي رياضه واحرق ويروح النادي يطلع
خلاص يقول انا الان حقوق في الميزان الاقي
الدنيا تغيرت ترى هذه خمسه في المئه اللي
انت بتسويها ما يحتاج تعمل كل هذا المجهود
عشان تنحف لان هو اصلا ولا شيء رياضتك
اللي انت سويتها تمثل كم
من الاربعه وعشرين ساعه في عمرك يعتبر
انسان اذا حتسوي رياضه كل ساعه طيب 23
ساعه هل منطقي انه في الساعه هذه
انت بتحرق فيها اكثر من 23 ساعه ما هو
منطق
ممكن
اكثر بالضبط ليش لانه في عمليات كثير
بتصير في الجسم بالتالي بتعطيك السعرات
هذه
يعني لما اجي اقول لك يعني
امشي ما اعرف يعني في واحد كان يمشي يوميا
ساعه تقريبا ومشي خفيف
وبعدها يشرب ومعرف ايش
هي هي شفت المجهود اللي عمله في هذا المشي
على طول عوضوا دوب وصرف دوب ورجع
هنا طب ايش ايش اهميه الرياضه ايش انواع
الرياضه
الرياضه انت عندك تقريبا نوعين اساسيه
مقاومه
وكارديو اللي هي لياقه
اللياقه او الكارديو اهمتها في الصحه حتى
الثانيه لكن تحديدا الفائده الاساسيه
الصحه صحه ايش صحه القلب ترى لما تيجي
تتمرن بتتحرك
الفائده والصحه هنا في تنشيط الدوره
الدمويه
اللي هي دورها ايش يعني انا ابغى اعمل هذا
الشيء عشان احمي نفسي
من الجلطات
الجلطه شبابها يعني في عده اسباب لكن من
ضمنها اللي هو الخمول او عدم الحركه الدم
لازم يدور عشان لا يركض وتتكون الجلطه في
الرياضه او الكارديو هنا دورها متى اسميها
كارديو
هل مشي في المول وده يعتبر لا
النشاط الرياضي
لازم يكون محدد له مده زمنيه وشده
لازم ايش هي اصلا التوصيات يقول لك لازم
تمشي ساعتين ونص في الاسبوع
في الاسبوع هذا الحد الادنى
لو سويتها ما تعتبر شخص خامل
ساعتين ونص قسمها براحتك
بس ساعتين ونص اعملها بشده اللي يصير فيها
ارتفاع في ضربات القلب
يعني اعطيني مثلا اذا قسمناها ممكن تيجي
22 23 دقيقه 23 دقيقه
في اليوم بشده متصله اقول لك خلاص انت
اتطمن ان شاء الله امورك كويسه هذا الحد
الادنى انا ابغاك تسوي لي الحد الادنى بس
هذه التوصيات القديمه
توصيات الجديده يقول لك ساعتين ونص زائد
يومين تمارين مقاومه اللي ما حد يسويها
ايش اهميه المقاومه اذا عرفنا اهميه
اللياقه اهميه المقاومه اول حاجه في جوده
الحياه الحركه القوم يعني لما نيجي نتكلم
على الشيخوخه
لما اجي اقول شيخوخه يجي في بال الناس
شعره بالتجاعيد زهايمر بس في يعني يعني
شيء بيصير في اغلب الناس اللي عندهم
شيخوخه اللي ضمور العظام والعضلات
تمارين المقاومه
مهمه في هذا الجانب زائد
اني احافظ على معدل الحرق واقول لك الواحد
كل ما يكبر
كل ما الحرق عنده يقل
هل ضروري لا
هو قلبي بشكل مره بسيط بس هو بيكبر في
العمر حرقه بيقل لانه
بيخسر عضل فحرقوا بيقل
فهل انا لازم امرن كل الناس حديدي ولازم
كل الناس يتمرن تمارين مقاومه مو حديد
تحديدا للمقاومه تقدر تعملها باي شيء
مقاومه
مو لازم امرنك كانك رايح تنافس في بطوله
ولا شيء احرك عضلاتك بس
حفز العضلات هذه عشان
تمنع امور مره كثيره من ضمنها زياده الوزن
من ضمنها جوده الحياه الحركه الوقفه من
الكرسي طلوع الدرج الشيل اغلب الام
الرقبه الظهر يجي لك يقول لك عندي ابهر
طيب لانك ما بيتحرك عضلاتك اصلا ابهر هذه
اللي هي العقد العضليه
ما حد بيحرك عضلاته الفكره انه العضله
بيصير فيها انقباض وانبساط انقباض انبساط
فلما بترجع العضله بتلقى صار في زي العقده
جزء رجع جزء وما رجع طبعا كيف اعدلها هذه
لازم امرن هناك لازم مره ثانيه اعمل لك زي
التشحيم فهمت لما اعمل لك التمارين تفك
خلاص كذا انت تعرفه كل انا اكبر واحد عندي
في العياده بمرنو
او يعني بوجهه في التمرين في الستينات
عمره
في البدايه يقول لي لا يا ولدي انا ما
ابغى اصير عضلات
ترى مره صح ما حتصير مره صعبه بس اتحرك
جرب اسمع كلامي مره واحده قال لي طيب بسمع
كلامي
الزياره اللي بعدها جاء جانب بلبس رياضي
يعني وريني انه نشوف النتيجه كيف علي
ومبسوط يقول لي انا ما تخيلت ما اتخيلت
انه الالام حتختفي مني وما بتكلم على شكل
الجسم وبيتكلم على جوده حياه الالام
بتختفي مني نومي صار احسن مزاجي صار احسن
يصير تحس ان انا بعمل شي لنفسي بدل ما انا
جالس في البيت بس كذا
فهذه المعلومات اللي قليل انها بتنذكر انه
لازم تعمل تمارين المقاومه روح سوي رياضه
روح امشي طب امشي قديش ايش الشده
ما حد بيقول روح اتمرن سوي رياضه بالذات
للسيدات
عشان
في معتقد خاطئ انه السيده اذا اتمرنت راح
تعطل ويخرب جسمها الانثوي هذا ما له علاقه
هذا غير صحيح
يعني
المسؤول عن بناء العضلات والضخامه هذه
اللي هو الهرمون الذكوري
فعند الاناث لما يجي يتمرنوا الجسم يصير
شكله الطبيعي والعضلات تنشد
بهرموناتهم بشكل الجسم الانثوي فشد الجسم
اذا احنا بنتكلم يعني ليش الناس اصلاوا
رياضه بسببين يا اما صحه
مهتم في الصحه او عشان شكله الجسم زي ايش
اغلب الشباب اهم شيء عنده شكل الجسم
ابغى اوصل الوزن المثالي
توصل الوزن المثالي لكن
ليست راضيه عن النتيجه او ليس راضيه عن
النتيجه هذا ايش معناته الوزن المثالي لا
يعني الجسم المثالي
الجسم المثال انتوا تتكلموا على مظهر
واكثر شيء يؤثر على المظهر
شكل العضلات
اليد اللي تكون راخيه على تحت غير انه جلد
هذا اصلا العضله نفسها ضعيفه مترهله فانت
كل اللي تبي تلمها بس
بكل بساطه وهلا لازم يوميا لا
توصيات ساعتين ونص
ماشي او كارديو دراجه سباحه او
او يومين في الاسبوع تتمرن فيها تمارين
مقاومه نص ساعه في اليوم بس يعني تخيل ان
انا اجي اقول لك انت شخص غير خامل
لانه في ناس يحسوا بتانيب ضمير انه والله
الناس بسوي رياضه وانا مشغول في حياتي
ماني قادر اسوي شي
اذا مشيت ساعتين ونص في الاسبوع واتمرنت
نص ساعه نص ساعه يومين منفصله انت كذا
خلاص امورك في السليم بس انت المشيها عندك
مشكله انه المشي حق المجمعات هذه مو صحيح
زاد مشي اللي مثلا نص ساعه يوميا ولا ساعه
يوميا امشي في مجمع اذا يعني تبغى الظل ده
بس امشي امشي سريع مشي سريع فتره متصله
مو شفت محل ادخل
اطلع لا لا يعني هذا عشان نسميه
في نادي وكده امشي في اي مكان تبغى اتمرن
باي اداه قدامك
التمارين
راحت عن بالي راحت عن بالك طب انا بجيب لك
كم حاجه جيب ذكرتني انه بسالفه التكميم
[موسيقى]
ايش فكره التكميم يعني ايش الخطا من
التكميم ليش في ناس
يرجعوا
يا سلام
فحكيني عن التكميم ومتى يكون صحي مثل
الواحد فعلا فعلا الان انت العلاج
والتكميم
شوفوا التكميم يعتبر الحل النهائي للسمنه
وكل ما عجلنا في خساره الوزن كل ما كان في
صالح الشخص
بالذات على الام الركب ومشاكل القلب
فالتكميم بكل بساطه
يشيله جزء صغير او جزء كبير من المعده
بالتالي الشخص من اول لقمتين
فل يشبع ما يقدر ياكل فاللي سووه انه بس
خلوه
ياكل اقل
الصرفيات زي ما هي بس انا ما اعطيته شي
يضطر الجسم ياخذ من طاقه نفسه الين ينحف
ويسهر خلاص صغر الشخص نحف
بعد مده تقريبا بعد سنتين النتيجه تثبت
بعد مده في فئه يمكن يوصلوا 30% منهم
وزنهم يبدا يزيد
يزيد ويرجع زي اول واسوء ايش اللي صار
ما عدل سلوكياته ما عدل النمط
التكميم اجبروا يوقف
الى فتره معينه لكن ايش اللي صار
المحركات الثلاثه اللي قلنا عليها اللي هي
الحرق الجسم والى اخره
وخسر المحرك او جزء من المحرك الاساسي
اللي هي العضلات
نحيف خسر دهون وعضلات
يترهل بعدها
لما خسر العضلات معدل الحرق حقه شبه العدم
بالتالي
الاكل اللي كان ينزل وزنه ساره الان يزيد
وزنه مو الاكل الكميه حق الاكل كميه
السعرات اللي كانت المفروض تنزل وزنه صارت
وزنه من لقمتين
يزيد يزيد
فمين هم اكثر ناس يستفيدوا من التكميم
الناس اللي هم بينحفوا بنشتغل على
سلوكياتهم هي مساله تروح تسوي عمليه واروح
بيتك لا سوي عمليه
روح نادي وابدا انسى طريقه حياتك القديمه
لانه هذه الطريق هو اللي وصلك لهذا الوزن
اذا رجعت عليه مئه في الميه راح ترجع لنفس
الوزن حقك ما فيها نقاش
الناس اللي سووا العمليه
لازم يكون عندهم سمنه مفرطه او سمنه
مصاحبها امراض يعني شخص عنده سمنه وسكري
حيستفيد من العمليه مره لكن
الحل الجراحي بشكل عام اخر خطوه ما هو اول
خطوه
شفت لما قلت لك في البدايه الناس في مرحله
ما قبل التامل والتامل اللي هو ما عنده
يعني عارف انه في مشكله بس ما يفرق معاه
في ناس تكون عزيمتهم جدا ضعيفه جدا جدا
جدا جدا جدا ضعيفه
نحاول نعمل لهم تاهيل نغير سلوكهم
مو شرط ننجح ما ننجح
عندك هذا الحل
نفس موضوع الابر التخسيس الان يعني هي
الموضه الجديده بس كم قيمه العبر تتجاوز
الف
مش تسوي الابر دورها باختصار بدون تفاصيل
وفلسفه تبطئ الجهاز الهضمي
بالتالي
ما راح تجوع بالتالي راح تاكل اقل بالتالي
المدخولات اقل اكيد وزنك ينزل طيب استخدمت
الابر انا اقول لك راح تنحف
وقف الابر ايش حيصير فيك ترجع ليش لانه ما
عدلت سلوكياتك فانا افضل وقت
الاستخدام الابره مو من البدايه انا اشتغل
احاول اصلح لما الاقي وزنك يبدا ينزل
لكن
تحتاج دفعه
في عندك اللي هو يسموها النعم يبقى ياكل
بزياده ما هو قادر حتى انا عدلت سلوكياته
وبالاكل الطبيعي او الاكل اللي في البيت
ما زال بياكل هنا في مشكله وباب ثاني
ينفتح اللي هو هرمون الجوع والشبع في ناس
عندهم مقاومه هرمون الشبع شفت مقاومه
الانسولين
مقاومه هرمون الشبع
هذا ايش يعني يعني المفترض الان
بعد ما اكل المفترض انه يشبع الجسم بيرسل
اشارات انه وقف بس الاشارات ما بتوصل
شغاله كمل
فهذا حيستفيد من الابره
لانه اول ما وجدنا ينزل المقاومه هذه راح
تختفي بالتالي لما نسحب الابره ما حيصير
شيء لانه وقفنا اصلا مشكله بسبب وزنه فهنا
دوره تدخلات الدوائيه لها اعراض جانبيه ما
هي امنه 100% الناس بيستخدموها هم اصلا ما
يحتاجوها يعني بنزل 4 كيلو يقوم يشتري
الابره وينزل وفي النهايه بتجيب اعراض
جانبيه جهاز هضمي ويروحوا على الطوارئ
للاسف
على يعني عجله ناس حبوا العجله ما حد يبغى
المسار الطبيعي الصحيح بدون لف ودوران
ولما تيجي يعني لما نيجي بنقول لهم
المعلومه وحده
تسوي كذا بس بس
اللي يعطيني الحبه السحريه
حوارق الدهون ابغى استخدم خل التفاح سمعت
انه خل التفاح هنا
طيب ولا علم السعرات هذا اللي قلنا
المصروفات خلت التفاح ايش حيسويها
هيحرق هيحرق هيحرق اسنانه
بس لا لا
زي الشاي الاخضر
مثلا الزنجبيل يعني بعض المشروبات ما
تساعد في سرعه الهضم وغيره نهائيا
[موسيقى]
انت شفت الثلاثه المحركات
اللي ايش جسمك يحرق
ونشاط والجسم بيهضمه فين مكان
الحاجات الخارجيه اللي بتدخل وبتحرق هو
كلمه حرق
هذا بيسير لانه في عمليات بتشتغل الان
طب فين العمليه
في اني مثلا
اللي بنتكلم كشركه مثلا
ما في مشروبات او اكل او حتى حبوب تساعد
في سرعه الهضم
اذا قلت سرعه او في تكسير الغذاء او في
هذا الشيء
اذا قلت سرعه الهضم فهذا معناته انا راح
اجوعك اكثر ليش لانه الابره عكس هذا
الكلام الابره تبطئ الهضم
بالتالي الاكل يبقى في جسمك فتره طويله
فهذه الابره ايوه تاثيرها هنا هل في دوا
ثاني في دواء ثاني
اللي هو اسمه
العلمي ما هو الاسم التجاري الاسم العلمي
حق هذا الدواء الاورليستات فائدته لما
تاكل وتاخذ هذه الحبه يقلل من امتصاص
الدهون في هذه الوجبه
يعني اكلت كميه زيوت كبيره هذا الدواء
يساعد انه اغلب الزيوت هذه تنطرد
فعيبه من اعراض الجانبيه الدهون هذه
بتنطرط من فين من الفضلات فراح ممكن يسبب
اسهال دهني
فهمت وادي مزعجه للناس يقول لك لا والله
استخدمت
ما شعور ما هو مريح فتلقام يوقفه بس
الادويه الثانيه اللي ممكن تؤثر
في الوزن
حاجات لها علاقه بالنفسيه
فهمت انه
الاكل او الرغبه في الاكل هذه لها علاقه
بالمزاج عشان كذا انا قلت لك في البدايه
الناس يفكر ان الاكل بس
التحكم في الوزن عباره عن اكل ورياضه لكن
في الجانب النفسي اللي هو سبب عدم
الالتزام هذا هو الاساس هو الجانب اللي ما
حد يتكلم فيه ابدا من وين جاءت سالفه
او حتى المشروبات الديتوكس وغيره يعني
من وين جت هالفكره اذا مالها اثر على ضبط
الهضم
شو في من فين جات الله اعلم تمام لكن
اعتقد اذا ابغى يعني
اتخيل نفسي فيه وتمكن لها اساس علمي
واستخدامها صار خطا هي لها اساس في ارضاء
الضمير بس طيب
بس اذا يعني استخدمته في الوقت الصح يعني
يعني كل كويس واشرب شاي اخضر اقول لك
ممتاز جدا يساعد بس
خابصه الدنيا كلها بعدين اني ياخذ الشاي
الاخضر لا ما له علاقه ابدا ما له علاقه
يعني من الحاجات التسويقيه يقول لك حبوب
الشاي الاخضر المركزه اللي حرق الدهون
ما لها اي علاقه هي انا يعني المساله كلها
ايش داخل وايش طالع بس ما حتقدر تاخذ شيء
يعني حتى الابر هذه انت ما تاخذها
وتنحف وانت كذا جالس يعني اذا اخذتها
وشديت على نفسك في الاكل ان هي تسد الشهيه
مره
في ناس عندي بياخدوها وزنها
يقول لك اوكي انا ما اتحمل اكل بس شغال
عصيرات
فهمت يعني اسرع شيء من عيوب العصيرات انه
ما في عمليه المضغ وعمليه المضغ تساعد على
الشبع لانه الجهاز الهضمي بيتهيا من هذه
المرحله
يبدا يجهز انه هدي اشبع
فالناس من الحاجات اللي انا ملاحظه في
العياده الناس اللي ياكل
وما ينبغ ياكل ويبلع مشروب ياكل مشروب
هذول في العاده ياكلوا اكثر من غيرهم
بكثير مو عشان معده تتحمل لانه الشبعه
تاخر بس مو منطقي يعني مثلا ما ادري يعني
احيانا بالنسبه
ممكن بعض مرات كذا يعني شبع يتاخر دقايق
يعني عشر دقايق عشرين دقيقه عن مده الاكل
حسب الوجبه حسب السرعه يعني بنقيسها هل
نفس الوجبه هذه دائما الشبع يتاخر فيها
فهمتي بس انه هل ممكن يتاخر الشباب عادي
بس الى حد معقول بس زي ما قلت لك الناس
اللي اللي ما يمضغوا اكثر ناس في العاده
يزيد معهم الكميه الاكل
والناس اللي اكلوا بيتنا
ليش
ياخذ الرز
ضغط اعمل لي كتله مضغوطه
فاهم نفس فكره العصير
العصير ضغط فيه اربع برتقالات هذا ضغط
يمكن ثلاثه ملاعب ولا خمسه ولا عشره حسب
حجم اليد يعني
[موسيقى]
فهمت فهذا بالنسبه لي مشكله وحتى لما تاكل
من صحن كبير واحد او انك تاخذك صحن صح
يخصك صح صح
فمن ضمن النصائح اللي انا قاعد اقوله يعني
بيجيني مثلا اشخاص
من الاسئله اللي انا اسالها هل اللي في
البيت معك كمان وزنهم زايد ولا بس انت
لانه في العاده هو سلوك ماشي في العيله ما
هي مساله جينات الجينات لها دور بس مو
بهذا الشكل
ولدي بياكل زي الناس مع ذلك وزنه بيزيد
مين هم الناس احنا طب انت وزنكم زايد
فهمتني فلازم الكل يتصلح
فانا الكلام مثلا اللي اقوله لشخص اقول طب
انا عادي زوجتي تمشي بنفس هذا الكلام
والاثنين يجوا مبسوطين مع انه هي الجلسه
حق هذا الشخص
ايه انا ما أعطي برنامج
عشان كذا يعني في يعني في تويتر بتجيني
رسائل تعمل برنامج غذائي لا ما اعمل
برنامج غذائي ما يعني ما هو توجهي مو مو
هو الشيء اللي انت تحتاجه
البرنامج الغذائي انا بس كلمني انت اصلا
ايش تعمل وانا اقول لك امورك طيبه مش
مشكله مع النظام اللبن والتمر
هذا من الانظمه العجيبه
الانظمه العجيبه اللي ما اعرف من فين
بيجيبوها يعني
ملابس ضيق عليه جلس اسبوعين
ضبطت وبعدين
تورط هناك هي هذه الفكره الانظمه القاسيه
فيها رده فعل دائما من الجسم
لما
كان نظامك اقسى
كل ما كان رده فعل الجسم اقوى في التجويه
الشخص اللي حرم نفسه ونزل مره بسرعه عنده
قابلين انه وزنه
طبعا الانظمه انت سالتني في البدايه
الانظمه الغذائيه بشكل عام او الجداول هذا
اللي بنشوفه
نسبه الفشل فيها خلال
ثلاثه الى خمس سنوات ناس بالضبط الدراسه
كم تتجاوز الثمانين في المئه يعني كلها
فاشله
اذا بتكلم عن الغريب كلها فاشله فالمشكله
فين
البساطه طيب انت من الناس تنصح بتدوين
يعني انا كتبت والله اكلت سندوتش طحينه
طيب هذه دراسه
تجربه عملت بلاش اقول دراسه تجربه اتعملت
بس للتدوين جابوا مجموعه من الناس قالوا
اسمعوني ابغاكم تدونوا ايش الماكولات اللي
بتاكلوها خلال اليوم كامل
بياكلوا حاجات هم ما هم مستوعبينها انه
انا ماني مستوعب انه هل انا قاعد اكل
اربعه يوميا من هذا الشيء لا مو
فبالتالي غير من نفسهم ليه لانه
يعني الطريقه اللي انا اتبعها او جزء من
الطريق اللي انا احاول اطبقه مع الناس
اللي هو كل بوعي اللي هي جزء من التغذيه
الحدسيه يسموها لازم اخليك تستوعب شعور
الجوع والشبح حقك هل هو شعور حقيقي ولا ما
هو حقيقي
ايش الحاجات اللي تخليك يعني تاكل بوعي لا
تاكل قدامك تلفزيون مثلا
لانك هتاكل وانت متفرج ما انت مستوعب ايش
قاعد تعمل بالذات السناكات
يعني لو الصحن قدامك انا متاكد نهايه
الجلسه شبه مختفي ولا لو انت قاصد انك
تاكله ما راح تاكله ما تقدر تخلصه فهي هنا
الفكره كل بوعي
التدوين مو معناتك يوميا هذا الشيء ممل
هذا الشيء سيء
لكن ابغاك تدون بس كمده اسبوع مثلا اذا
عشان بس تعرف فين ممكن تلاقي الخلل
وهذا الشيء اطلبه من بعض الوان لما يقول
لي انا ما اكل غير وجبه واحده
مع الاسئله
وجبه من هنا سناك من هنا معرفه من هنا وهو
ماشي اشيل له حاجه زي كذا
فانت ما بتاكل وجبه واحده
بس هذه الحاجات الثانيه انت ما تعتبرها
وجبه وهي ما تعتبر وجبه كمان اي شيء
تاكلوه اعتبره وجبه كحسابيا يعني
يعني تفاحه من هنا
هذه ايش اسمها سناك طب سناك اذا لغينا
المسميات
فطور غدا عشاء سناك وجبه واحد وجبه اثنين
وجبه ثلاثه وجبه اربعه شوف العدد كم حيوصل
بسهل المنطقه انك تاخذ التفاح وجبه
لا يعني وجبه غير كامله
احنا ليش قلنا اصلا هذا الموضوع
لانك كنت تتكلم في التدوين يعني ايوه على
التدوين فهي بس هنا الفكره يعني سجل ايش
الحاجات اللي بتاكلها ونفس الشيء ترى
نعمله مع المدخنين
لانه احيانا بيدخنوا في اوقات كثيره
هم ما هم مستوعبينها لانها عاده
ففجاه يتفاجا انه في السياره بيدخن اغلب
الكميات او في غرفه معينه بيدخن اغلب
السجائر
فيجرب يخفف من هنا تلقاه انه قادر انه
جسمه ما هو طالبه
فالوعي له دور كبير في اتخاذ القرارات
عشان انا لازم اعلمك مو بس اقول لك سوي
افعل لا لازم انت اللي تتخذ القرارات هذه
بنفسك
على الملاحظات يعني اكيد انه الجوك الحين
يعني اذا 500
مراجع الشهر بدي اعرف شو الملاحظات اللي
تقدر تشكلها من سلوك الناس بالمجتمع
زي ما قلنا في البدايه اول شيء المشروبات
هذه لازم يبداوا يخلوها اللي هي صفر سعرات
هذه اول مقطع
ثاني نقطه
عدد التمر
ليش لانه احنا بنتكلم على حاجات زي ما انت
قلت في المجتمع
المغرب القهوه والتمر هذه دائما فيه فلازم
الواحد يتحكم في الكميه هذه لا تحطوا
الكميه كامله قدامك حط ثلاثه كفايه
النقطه الثالثه المكسر
يقول لك في تمر اقل سكر
لانه خليني اقول هذا النوع هو الكويس فيهم
اذا صعب الكميه مفتوحه تاكل الزياده
بالتالي حنفتح باب ثاني
الثالثه الثالثه ولا الثالثه
المشروبات التمر المشروبات التمر بعدها
المكسرات
ليه بحجه انها صحيه
فالكميه تصير مفتوحه وينصدمه لما نقول لهم
لا لازم تخفف طب كم قديش اخفف كم معرفه
بنفس حجم المكسرات مثلا الفستق يقول عشرين
حبه في اليوم
اللوز والكاجو مثلا عشر حبات في اليوم
البيكان والجواز مثلا هذه اربع حبات هذه
اذا انت تبغى تاخذ الفوائد الصحيه فيها
فهذا القدر كافي
عملها معامله الادويه الزياده ما راح
تفيدك زياده حتى تطلع لك الاعراض الجانبيه
اللي هي زياده الوزن مثلا
الرابع اللي هو ايش
الزيت اللي قاعد ينصب مع الاكل
الفول الحمص السلطه الاجبان كلهم يصبوا
عليها
الزيت وهذه بترفع السعرات يعني بشكل خيالي
يفرق الزيت في العصر البارده وعن غيره
يعني يفرق اذا بنتكلم كخصائص الزيت او
كطعم وده سعرات كل واحد ما يفرق
بالزيوت اي هذه قلناها الاربعه اذا ابى
اضيف خامس اللي هي الحاجات اللي بيشتروها
من البقاله والسوبر ماركت الشوكولاته
الشيبسات اذا نبغى نخليها يوميا او الشخص
دائما لازم ياكلها فاكتفي بنوع واحد ونوع
واحد اللي هو الحجم الاصغر كفايه ما اقول
لك ممنوع لا خذ القدر الكافي اذا تاكل
شوكولاته اربع اصابع خذ اصبعين كفايه
اذا تاخذ شيبس كيس كبير خذ الكيس الصغير
بس استمر زي ما انت
والحركه
الرياضه احنا قلنا في البدايه ساعتين ونص
وساعتين ونصف
ساعه على يومين اللي تمارين مقاومه
ممكن
ما ابغى احلف
بس كل اللي غيرناه لهم هذه الامور
اختلفوا وزنهم وصحتهم بس
ولا غيرت لهم وجباتهم الرئيسيه ولا حاجه
يعني ممكن بعضهم اشتغلنا في الوجبات
الرئيسيه في ايش
زود الدجاج بس
ولا جدول ولا اي حاجه هذه البساطه
والنتائج جدا جميله والناس بيطلعوا هم
مبسوطين
مين هم اللي طلعوا مبسوطين الناس اللي
اتقبلوا يسمعوا الكلام
لان في ناس ما عندهم قابليه خلاص
جاي يبغى حاجه معينه في باله
اللي هي ايش الابره
فهذولا يتعبونا في العياده انا احاول اصلح
له تفكيره
والناس اللي ما بيغيروا وزنهم كمان هذولا
يعني يعني تخيل احنا في العياده يعني هذا
دورنا
اني انا انصحك بس مو اجبرك وكلامي لازم
يكون معك من غير ما احكم عليك يعني انت
وزنك لانك وفيك وفيك وفيك وفيك لا بس في
ناس بيجوني يعني
بعقليه مستسلمه اقول لك خلاص انا كبير بعد
ايش
[موسيقى]
دكتور الموت واحد
فهمت بس
تشوف الكلام ممكن يكون يعني منطقي
بس مين اللي يرد عليه الشخص اللي في عمره
وعنده المشاكل الصحيه اللي ما طلعت لنا
يقول لك لا والله يا ريت يا ريت يا ريت
سويت كذا
يعني الناس هذول اللي يجوك مستسلمين او
الناس اللي ما يبغوا يتقبلوا
الطريق اللي هي العاديه هذه اللي احنا
بنقولها
يدور الطرق السريعه
الحبه المعرفه ضحايا
المفترسين الموجودين برا
الشركات المدربين خذ خذ خذ هات هات هات
الين الشخص هذا يصير وعاء
صدى
شخص غير حقيقي
[موسيقى]
نقال لكلام الشخص الثاني اللي بيعطي له
الامور هذه فتلقى بتصير في مهاجمات شوفوا
هذا ايش يقول انت غلطان وفي طب انت من فين
جايب العلم هذا معليش يعني
مين ايش مصدرك في هذا الكلام كله انت
والله مصدر فلان مين فلان فلان واحد معضل
طيب المعضل الان او اللي جسمه كويس كلمته
نوعا ما مو دائما بس الغالبيه كلمه اقوى
من المتخصصين
تمشي عليهم كمان
[موسيقى]
بايمان عجيب
وهنا يجي موضوع باب النجار مخلوع
[ضحك]
باب النجار مخلوع
مو مره احب هذه الكلمه
لانه في امور
يعني تقدر تحكم فيها امور ما تقدر تتحكم
فيها
فمثلا والله طبيب العيون يلبس نظاره طبيب
الجلديه عنده صرع اول مدري مين يدخن
والمدري
طيب
الحاجات الوراثيه
لا اعتراض خلاص هذا في الشخص عنده
مثلا مشاكل في نفس النظر اجباري يلبس
شخص حيصلع
هو طبيب جلدي
صلى وبيعالج ناس وبنشوف النتائج حقته
جميله ممتاز حاروح له ليش لا لان انا شايف
النتائج
هذا الشيء وراثي ما يقدر يتحكم فيه حيعمل
زراعه وممكن حتى انه زراعه يعني
التكنيك سيء بغض النظر عنده مرض
مناعي في امراض مناعيه تطيح الشعر تماما
هذه لو ايش تسوي
انه يعني ظاهر يعني
واضح انه مدح صادق
فعلا كذلك يعني في العين
بس كان الدكتور لابس نظاره
اوكي فقلت يا اليز يمكن والله استوقفتني
يعني كنت يمكن انه يعرف كيف تتسوى العيون
فيخاف عيونه ما أعرفه
انه الناس ايش يبغوا يشوفوا يشوفوا الكلام
اللي انت قاعد تقوله بغض النظر يعني انا
سالت السؤال هذا في حسابي
اذا رحت او نقلت تغريده عن احد الاطباء
هل ممكن تروح
لطبيب يعاني من السمنه
وانت
هدفك تخسر وزن
اغلب التعليقات بغض النظر صادقين او غير
صادقين تعرف السوشيال ميديا كثيرين يدعوا
المثاليه ويخافوا يقولوا رايهم الحقيقي
ليه عشان
التنمر ما التنمر خليك صادق يعني في هذا
رايك
ما عجبك يعني ما عجبنا رايك في النهايه هو
مجرد رايي
رايك او حاعلق على رايك فلقيت اغلب
التعليقات احسها يقول لك نعم انا حاروح له
ولو عندك لو نتيجته ولو مشتركين اللي جو
ولا غلطه طيب
لو حطيت قدامك شخصين
فلان جسمه مظهره ممتاز ونفس هذا الشخص
اللي عنده من السمنه
مع بعض الاثنين نتائجهم رهيبه للمشتركين
حتروح لمين
مين راح تختار
الثاني تلقائيا يقول لك انا ابغى عن هذا
من غير اصلا ما يعني
تلقاه هو اصلا لوحده وقاعد يمشي على هناك
وهذا الموقف صار لي في العياده واحد اول
ما دخل عندي العياده
فتح الباب طالع قال الحمد لله وجلس
[موسيقى]
طلعت انه ايش الدخل العجيبه هذه ايش في
قال لا انا قلت اذا دخلت ولقيت الدكتور
اللي قدامي وزنه زايد انا راح اطلع
فالناس يبغى يشوفوا الكلام اللي انت
بتقوله جالس تطبقه
عشان كذا
لاول الجلسه
ايش الفرق بين فلان وفلان وفلان قلت لك
الممارسه الكلام هذا اللي انا جالس اقوله
انا اقدر اقول لك كل العلم واشرح لك كل
العلم بس ايش الالقاب اللي التطبيق من هذا
العلم في حياتنا هنا في مجتمعنا
ليش انت قلت ليش ما صلح الصلع
اذا هو عنده صلع وراثي وصلح الصلع هذا انت
حتشوفه لانه هذا اللي انت تبغاه
طب انا ابغى كمان شخص
في عز الظروف هذه اللي احنا بنعيشها
الحياه الاكل العزايم او اشوف واحد محافظ
على نفسه واحد شاب عمره عشرين يتكلم في
هذه الامور ومره يعني حلفتني انا ابغى
واحد عمره قريب من عمري في الاربعين يتكلم
انا طبعا ماني في الاربعين بس في الاربعين
يعني انا اتكلم على همش واحد في الاربعين
ومحافظ على يعني وزنه وعلى شكله وعلى
كتلته هذا يعني يعتبر اكبر قدوه
لو مئه دكتور بيقولوا لا تعمل الشيء وهذا
فلان بيقول له اعمل والله لا يسمع كلامه
كل يوم اشرب عسل على الريق وخد الخل
وتلقاه يسوي زيه ويطبقها خلاص
لازم الشخص هو اللي يكون القدوه وعلى اثر
الرياضه والاكل الصحيح في الشباب او على
على حياتك لما تكبر في الحلقه السابقه
الحلقه القديمه سويتها مع ادم فيتكلم على
اثر هذه الاشياء
بتكون في وصف هذه الحلقه
يعني في عمرك من العشرينات الى الاربعينات
ياثر على هذاك الوقت في الشيخوخه والمراد
الزهايمر وغيره والسرطان وكله يعني شيء
مذهل يعني طبعا هي نتيجه تراكميه كانت
الان عندك مشكله وحليتها الان تمام لكن هل
المشكله هذه عملت يعني
اعراض تراكميه ولا لا
تشوفها يعني
في نقطه
اتكلم فيها في جروب رياضي عن
المنشطات والامور هذه كلها اللي بتصير
داخل الانديه
فانقسموا يعني اجسام في ناس بيقول لك لا
في ناس بياخدوها وما بيصير في ناس
بياخدوها وبيموتوا اللي بيموتوا ايش كان
السبب الوفيات اغلبهم يعني او نسبه منهم
جلطات
طب الجلطات هذه لما هو بياخد الهرمونات
وبعدها بمده يحلل ويلقى نفسه طبيعي
بعدين ياخذ
الدفعه اللي بعدها بعدين يحلل ويلاقي نفسه
طبيعي طب ليش جاله وهو بيلاقي كل مره نفسه
طبيعي
انت بتحلل في هذه اللحظه بس في لحظات
ثانيه انت ما بتحلل فيها انت بتحلل في هذه
اللحظه لانك في هذه اللحظه انت صلحت كل
شيء فانت شفت هذا التاثير لكن على المدى
البعيد في امور بسيطه
بتترك اثر سلبي
وتحط نقطه سوداء نقطه سوداء نقطه وبتكمل
عليها زي موضوع
الزيوت المهدرجه كل ما يعني
يطول استخدامها وحتى لو جات فتره مثلا
صلحت ما زال انت تحت التاثير
وكل ما صلحت وجلست فتره وانت
يعني صحي راح تبدا تنعكس هذه الامور
للافضل لكن مو شرط انه مئه في الميه يتصلح
رمضان الله الله رمضان على الابواب يعني
حلقه في رمضان باذن الله هذا علشان بس
احنا
اثنين
كيف يعني ادري انه الاكل
واعتقد انه اغلب الناس تعرف ايش المشاكل
تصير الاكل المقليات تصير اكثر ما ادري
شلون ينزل لك هنا كيف اكل لا ينتهي يعني
انت تجي اصلا كميه الاكل عن ايامك العاديه
لانه في فتره قصيره
بس بدي اعرف ايش الشكل المثالي ممكن اقدر
اتبعه وفقا لي ان هذا السلوك هو الدارج
كنت ما ودك برضو ننزل فطور ما تنزل معاهم
ينزل سحور ما تنزل معاهم وهكذا
كيف ممكن يكون رمضان
غذائيا جيد هو زي ما احنا قلنا
كل ما زودنا البروتين كل ما كان الموضوع
احسن غالبا في رمضان فين مصادر البروتين
اللي بتلقاها اخلى السمبوسه مثلا او اللحم
اللي يكون مثلا مع الشوربه في الغالبه
فانا بالنسبه لي من اجمل
الاختيارات في الاكل الشوربه
فكلهم اجلس اقول لهم زود في الشوربه قد ما
تقدر
وزود اللحم اللي تضيفه مع الشوربه لانه
هذا هو الاساس حقك
بالنسبه
للسمبوسه ماء مو مره تفرق معايا من ناحيه
النوم هل هي مقليه ولا هل هي بالقلايه
الهوائيه يعني
حتفرق شيء بسيط
بس في النهايه يعني سواء مثلا
اعملت مثلا
فهنا بس اعمل كنترول فيها خلاص خمسه حبات
مره بالكثير ثلاث حبات حلوه
في ناس يحطوا مثلا الفول مع الفطور الفول
ممتاز جدا زيد في الفول مو لازم تاكله
بالملعقه
زيت في الفول الاصناف اللي فيها بروتين
عالي هذه هي اللي توصف فيها وبالنسبه
للحلا دائما ينزل عامله نفس معامله التمر
التمر احنا قلنا ثلاثه حبات
الحلا جيبه بنفس الطريقه ان كنت انت تحب
كذا عينك تشبع بالاكل انه لازم اشوف الطبق
ده والطبق كبير بس تشاركوا معها
فهمت في ناس يقول لك لا انا لازم عيني
تشوف
والمقليات برضو نفس الشيء يعني انك تقلل
الكميات
وغيرها هو يعني شهر واحد هو شهر واحد يعني
ما عندي مشكله انه اتقدم
في موضوع الوزن 11 شهر
وشهر واحد
اعطي بريك وهذه هي فرصته ان هو اصلا الجسم
يحتاج كل فتره يعني احنا قلنا تخسيس ما
ينفع طول الوقت يمشي تخصيص حتى لو حتى لو
في نتائج بعد مده الافضل انه اوقفك اعطيك
قد الاحتياج حقك
اثبت كده فتره
بعدين نرجع نكمل فالفتره فرصتها في رمضان
فما هو وقته انه يعني
زي ما تقول ايش تجتهد
تلقائيا في ناس اصلا برنامجهم في رمضان
تلقاهم ينحفوا لوحدهم
خلاص هذا ما راح اعلم وايش
هعلق في الناس اللي وزنهم يزيد وهي
بالملاحظات اللي قلنا عليها
وتحديدا المشروبات زي ما انت قلت فهمته
في الان المشروبات هذه اللي هي التوت
الجديده الشركات نزلت
الشركات الثانيه كمان نزلوا زيرو يعني ما
في سكر طب الناس بيضيفوه وبيضيفوا سكر في
محليات الصناعيه كمان شوف ايش النكهه اللي
اتقبلها لسانك
خذ راحتك في رمضان
يفرق اذا انه بتاكل وجبه الفطور كثير ولا
انك تقسمها ولا من فرق
حسب انت كيف يعني مثلا في ناس يقول لك اذا
انا فطرت
بعد يعني اكلت شيء خفيف لبن مثلا وتمر
بعدين رحت المسجد اصلي وارجع احس انه
شهيتي مو مره باكل خفيف واقوم كله ممتاز
كمل زي ما انت
في ناس
يعني من البدايه الله
كل شيء يخلص
هنا لا اسمع جرب سوي كذا هذول اللي اعمل
فيهم تعديلات الناس اللي جاهزين خلاص ما
اشتغل عليهم المويه يقول لك في كثره
المويه تسمم مويه تسمم لا مستحيل صعب
صعب جدا انك توصل لمرحله تسمم صعب وشبه
مستحيل نعم مستحيل
يعني تقريبا حالتين اللي ممكن يصير فيها
تسمم
اما اعطيك يعني عن طريق الوريد
هذا سهل انك تطلع فيها اكياس ما توقف خلاص
يعني او بالغلط يعني من الاخطاء الطبيه او
الشخص
ما هو
سوي
عقليا عنده احد مثلا الامراض النفسيه
اللي ما في تحكم نهائيا
في اي قرارات او وعي ما في بصيره انه يفكر
زي الحالات اللي مثلا بيدخلوا في الطوارئ
يقول لك
مثلا العاب ماكل خيمه هم كبار ما هم صغار
فهذول نفسهم هم اللي ممكن
يتسمم يشرب يشرب يشرب
لكن اذا انت شخص طبيعي وجيت تشرب جرب اغسل
بنفسك على كميه الشرب
ما راح تقدر
ما تقدر
متى تصير انه عندك تسمم
هي يعني بس كميه يعني
قصدك بالشرب ما تصير يعني تبغاها من الاخر
مستحيل مستحيل اشربه براحتكم مره لا تخاف
اعرف هذه المعلومات هي اللي بتطلع من
المواقع والمنتديات والامور هذه كلها ولو
تلاقي مين مين الكاتب حقها
مجرد صحفي مجتهد او كاتب مجتهد في
المواضيع الطبيه
يقول لك كذا نهائيا ممكن طبيب ومحتوى
[ضحك]
الله يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك يا هلا
والله شكرا لكم شكرا لترك القحطاني في
اعداد الحلقه وهاب موسى في التصوير عبد
المجيد العطاس في التلوين
وجميل ومحمد الحسن في الهندسه الصوتيه
وفي اداره محتوى التواصل نوره السبيعي
واداره التحرير اسيل بعبد الله هذا فنجان
احد منتجات شركه تمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه الرياض
الاسبوع المقبل القاكم
قديش اخذنا
ضحكنا
ما ادري ايش كنت تتكلم ولقيته على جنبه
يضحك
أنا
ترى اتشتت مره بسرعه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
قبل الفطور نرجع
طيب مثل واحد يتمرن في رمضان حسب جدولك
حلو سؤال مره مهم في رمضان او خارج رمضان
متى افضل وقت للتمرين في الوقت المناسب
لجدولك مسروح اتمرن
بهذه البساطه بس يعني عادي لو بعد الاكل
يعني اذا انا اقدر عادي بعد الاكل عادي
اثناء الفطور بس يقول لك انه قبل الفطور
عشان تحرق اكثر
على حسب جدولك بالنسبه للفوائد في يعني
بعض
الدراسات تدعم هذه الفكره انه في اخر
الصيام ان اتمرنت فان تكون في قمه الفوائد
الصحيه
بس مو
ما لا علاقه
والوزن شويه منفصله بس مرتبطه وعلاقه
معقده شويه
في من النصائح المهمه
للاشخاص اللي هم وزنهم زائد يعني هم يعني
اتوقع هم اكثر ناس ممكن يستفيدوا في هذه
الحلقه
لما نيجي شخص يقول له روح امشي
على الناس اللي يعانوا من السمنه المفرطه
[موسيقى]
المشي متعب لهم ممكن يكون مضر لهم
فيعني
من الحاجات اللي ما بتنقال اي واحد يعني
عنده سمنه مفرطه المفترض
يعني يستخدم المسبح او في حال ما كان
متوفر المسبح دراجه منزليه
هو جالس مكانه زي كذا يحرك العجله برجله
لانه ما وزنه ما هو واقف على المفصل وما
عمل ضغط بس على الاقل الين ما نبدا ننزل
وزنه بعدين يبدا يروح يمشي
والناس المبتدئين مو شرط من البدايه تبدا
تمشي يعني خمسين دقيقه اربعين دقيقه ابدا
بالتدرج البطيء انت الان من الرياض اللي
راح تعملها في اول شهر ما راح تشوف نتيجه
ولا تخلي هدفك انك تشوف نتيجه الهدف
الاساسي هو بناء العاده فقط
التزم استمر
بالطريقه اللي تكون مناسبه لك
لا يا يوسف الكلام اللي قلته تقدر تطبقه
يعني احس ان اكثر شيء كنت بحاول اسويه حتى
انه يمكن تيجي مثلا اشترك في نادي ولا شي
اتعمد انه يكون حر طيب فما يصير التعني له
خارج عن عاداتك اليوميه فهو جنب البيت
تقدروا يا سلام الاكل ما اتطلب وجبه معينه
صعبه انك تجيبها
في اي وقت اي وقت مطعم قريب مني اقدر اخذ
ادور اللي
صعبته اكبر فهو يعني من افضل الطرق انك
تبني عاده
انك تربط العاده الجديده بعد انت بتعملها
بشكل يومي فمثلا انا عن نفسي في اوقات
كثير اذا رجعت البيت بعد الدوام ما اقدر
اخرج
ما اقدر اطلع من البيت أيش افضل حل اخذ
معي اغراضي من بعد الدوام او من قبل
الدوام تروح لانه
الروحة للنادي نوعا ما اصعب من النادي
نفسه اذا وصلت خلاص انت امورك كويسه من
اكثر
النصائح المدمره اللي بنشوفها في
المراجعين
لما اقول له روح نادي يا دكتور انا رحت
وخلصت واشتراكي اشتركت سنه وما رحت غير
شهر شهرين ليش
المدربين في الانديه بيقولوا لهذه الفئه
لا انت ما ينفع تتمرن حديد انت تروح على
اجهزه اللياقه
ما يخليهم يمشي نص ساعه نص ساعه نصف ليش
هذا الشيء يعني في ناس انا اراسلهم وكاتب
لهم كذا برنامج انه ايش تروح تسوي في
النادي
يعني كذا قاعد على البرنامج اللي انا كده
بيتطور اروح ارسل شخص يقوم يرجع لي يلاقي
المدرب يقول له لا تسوي كذا اقوم ازيد في
الملاحظات يقوم يرجع واحد ثاني اقوم ازيد
البرنامج قاعد يتطور
في فكره سائده اللي هي ما ينفع تتمرن حديد
الا لما تنحف عشان ما ينفع تبني
العضلات على الشحوم ما لها علاقه سمعتها
صح
ما لها علاقه اساسا كل شخص
دخل في انظمه غذائيه وخرج ونحف وزن وزاد
نحف ويسموه تاثير اليويو يويو
اللي تربطها تنزل نزول طلوع نزول طلوع اي
شخص مر في مرحله اليويو او تاثير اليويو
هذا الحرق عنده شبه العدم ما راح يتصلح
الا لما يتمرن حديد
فلما
الاشخاص يروحوا النادي ويلاقوا مدربين
يستقبلوهم بهذه المعلومات
خلاص يصير في تخبط في المعلومات
ما اقدر اتمرن اتمرن انا ما استفيد جسمي
في شيء غلط
المعلومات غلط الدكتور ما يفهم والمدرب ما
يفهم وانا ما افهم
فمن جد يشكل فوضى وينزل لي مع
هو هذا
المساله كلها بس تحتاج يعني
تبسيط للامور ما نبغى التفصيل التفصيل حلو
للمهتم
انت مهتم تبي تطور ادائك واح فصل اقرا
اعطيك التفصيل لكن انت كشخص عامي ما تحتاج
ما تحتاج التمرين في الصباح طب شده
التمرين انا الوزن قد ايش اخففه هل اعمل
سوبر ست هل مو لازم انت بس روح اتمرن هذا
كلام حق ناس يعني مستوى متوسط الى متقدم
وماني اصلا توصل لهذا المستوى ان كان هدفك
بس تبي ترتب جسمك او تبي تحسن صحتك كل دي
التفاصيل انت ما تهمك
[موسيقى]
اسلوب اسلوب من الصيام المتقطع
صيامه
يا سلام ومن يساعد اذا كانت
اربع ساعات ست ساعات صار مجموعه اللي هو
السياره المتعارف عليه اللي هو
بس يعني زي ما تقول ايش
كيف اتفنن كيف يعني الاشخاص اللي بيطلعوا
كيف يتفنن في خلق عجز السعرات
كيف انا اخليك تقلل اكلك بحركه فنيه وارمي
بعدها اي اسم انا عندي اشكاليه
بس مشكله الاكل حلو حلو
تمر ايام اروح النادي كل اسبوع كامل
هنا يعني
زي ما قلنا ايش الامور القابله للتطبيق في
هذا الموقف للشخص اللي جدا مشغول فيهم وما
يقدر يعني يغطي احتياجه مثلا من البروتين
في وجبات مره سريعه تقدر تعملها وهذه هي
المهمه يعني بالنسبه لك
زي مثلا اللبن اليوناني او الحليب
اليوناني هذه تقطع لك شوط اذا خليتها
اثنين في اليوم مثلا علبه الحليب او اللبن
زائد اللبن الزبادي وتحط معه مثلا توت
مجمد اللي يجي في الاكياس خلاص ترميه رميه
زي كذا ويجي معاه الشوفان او الجرانولا
مثلا يجي كذا مقرمش برضو تكبه كده شيء على
السريع تعرف اللي هي غرفه غرفه غرفه خلاص
وانت ماشي تقدر تعملها
هذه
لوحدها يمكن اعطتك
نص الاحتياج هذه بس الطريقه الطريقه
الثانيه اللي هي انت قلت المطاعم هذه انها
هي تجيب لكن هذه ما هي مناسبه لك احنا في
عندي مطعم في جده صراحه
رهيب انا المطعم الوحيد اللي متقبله فيهم
كلهم
ايش اسم المطعم سالوس ايد سالوس
يعني اكل حقيقي
مو 150 150 وتجيب لي وانا ناشف كانه يعني
يعني حتى قالوا
اطعم من ايش اطعم من
اكل المستشفيات
اطعم من المطاعم هذه
الطريقه الثالثه انا قلت الطريقه الثالثه
لازم انت تحضر الاكل مسبقا
مثلا او حق على الاقل ثلاثه ايام
يعني انا زوجتي يعني هي اللي يعني عادتا
بتسوي شغل البيت بس بتجيها سفريات
اتورط انا خلاص استناها لن ترجع لا عندك
حلول
عندي القلايه الهوائيه وعندي قدر ضغط في
دجاج اللي هو
البحر المتبل الجاهز
زي ما هو
في القلايه الهوائيه
30 دقيقه يطلع مستوي
خمس نجوم في كل النكهات
كبسه برياني هندي سبايسي
كلها جربتها اطعم وحده اظن اليوم
اليوم المهم انه الكيس حق الدجاج ازرق
وقدر الضغط قدر الضغط الكهربائي طبعا
[موسيقى]
ليش لانه اجي بس كذا احط الرز
والحاجات الثانيه
الثوم البودره البصل البودره البهارات
كبسه زيت زيتون صلصه طماطم ارمي احطها في
القدر
زي ما هم شفت انا انا سويت الرز الان حطيت
شغلت القلايه الهوائيه واخرج
سويت اموري خلصت ورجعت جاهز الدنيا كلها
قدامي
يعني
انا انسان جدا كسول انا لو في شيء يتطلب
مني اكثر من ثلاثه خطوات ما راح اسويها
وهذا الشيء عمل تغيرات داخل البيت كثيره
جنب الباب ايش فيه ايش اكثر من ثلاث خطوات
انا ما راح اسويه
يعني فاهم ايش الشيء اللي بتقوله وهذا هو
كان الحل انت بالنسبه لك شفت نظام
المحارب اللي هو وجبه واحده هذا هو انسب
نظام لك انت مشغول في الصباح مشغول في
المساء مثلا خلاص يا دوب ما عندك غير حق
وجبه واحده تقريبا هي اللي من جد حتتفرغ
لو صباح ليل صباح ليل وما عندك غير هذه
الوجبه اول ما ترجع
سوي كل هذا اللي انا قلته
والصباح تقدر تاخذ الحاجات السريعه اللي
قلت الصباح هذه الامور في الليل سوي هذه
وامورك
في السليم ممكنك المطاعم ممكن مطاعم يعني
مدري ايش هل ممكن لو ضبطت الوزني مره صعب
مره مره صعب يعني هو عادي بس الفكره انه
عشان تشبع خلاص اتجاوزت اصلا الشيء اللي
انت تحتاجه لان
طريقه الطبخ يعني الاكل اصلا كيف يصير مره
لذيذ
البهارات رقم واحد
الشيء الثاني كميه الزيت وكميه الملح هذه
الاطعمه لك الاكل
اذا سويت المعادله صح هشيل لك الممتاز
فعشان كذا اللي يقول لك الاكل الصحي شويه
ما هو لذيذ صحي
مو كله ممكن مو كله الاشكاليه في الصوصات
والله
في ناس يقولوا هذه الكلمه صح بس انا مثلا
الاكل اللي اسويه في البيت لنفسي انا اقدر
اكله ومره يعجبني زوجتي
[ضحك]
فهمت ما تاكله
فهنا يدخل الموضوع اللي يعني سوي الشي
اللي يناسبك انت بهاراتك بتتبيلتك به يعني
انا يعني ما حسوي فيها انا طباخ انا ماني
طباخ
يعني هي هذه اللي اعرفها بس يمكن بس
الفكره انها مره سهله وادت الغرض وانا جدا
راضي وكل ما
روتين مو مشكله لا ابدا بالعكس اسهل شيء
لك
واكثر شيء يريحك
انا قلت لك في البدايه الانظمه الغذائيه
قد ايش مريح نفسيا لما انت تكون عارف ايش
حتاكل ومتى حتاكل
هنا هو الهدف
البرامج تنوع البرامج هذه لانها مختلفه
حسب اسلوب حياه الشخص
انك تاكل في نفس الموعد كل يوم
يقول لك اذا حددته وقت الاكل ينضبط
هو صح صح
كذا حتى لو ايش سويت
لسه ابغى اسهر
تروح تنام على طول الاكل نفس الشيء اذا
انت متعود طول الوقت
تاكل تاكل تاكل تاكل يساعد في
الوزن والصحه ان يكون مرتب خلاص الاكل
مره مره يساعد ايش قلت لك في البدايه
حسب ما انت بتعود جسمك زي ما انت قلت هذي
حركه الامعاء اللي بنسير
دائما الخلل يبدا من شعور الجوع
هنا اللي ممكن تغلط زياده زي اللي يقول لك
لا ترسل جيعان يطلب
نفس الفكره الجيعان الان لما يجي ياكل اذا
هو مو مره مستوعب ايش بياكل حيغلط
فاذا انت متعود انك تاكل على مدار اليوم
الا في مكان معين حيصير فيه خلل
فاذا ارتب
الوجبات امورك كويسه انا في عندي ثلاثه
ثلاثه حاجات
يعني هي اللي انا ما احبها ابدا في الاكل
نهائيا يعني شوف انا مع المرونه مع كل شيء
رغم انه انا احيانا اضطر يعني يعني اخذ
منها قطع او شيء ثلاثه دونات
بيتزا شيبس
ثلاثه دولار
يعني
المفترض يعني
قطعه صغيره منهم فيها كميه سعرات عجيبه
عباره عن ايش عجينه زيت وحسب ايش الخبيصه
اللي فوقه او جوه تحت
البيتزا نفس الشيء
اللي اتعمل به العجينه
والجبنه اللي ما اتحطت معاها الصوص ايش
نوعه واذا انت حتحط فيها اصابع جبنه من
جوه ولا لا
ما يخلص يعني كيس واحد ما يكفي والله واحد
ورا واحد
اشتريت لسه الاسبوع اللي فات
زوجتي بتقول له جيب لي جيب لي
جيب لي شيء من السوبر ماركت يفرحني
فعاليات فعاليات متزوجين
قلت يلا
خليني افكر له ايش فيه يعني اكيد
فجبت واحد
طلعت واحد ثاني قلت هذا كمان ممكن
طلعت واحد ثالث يلا ثلاثه يا حبيبي
فاستخدمت جبت الثلاثه هذي في البيت
فرحت
فتحت واحد تبغى خذ يلا
شغلنا التلفزيون جالسين
خلص الاول اوف خلص ليش احنا المفروض نبقي
لا لا عادي طعم مو مشكله
في نص الجلسه ثاني انفتح كل اكياس كبيره
هنا هذه المشكله انه يعني هو طعم
وما في يعني في البيت هذا شيء عادي يعني
احنا في النهايه يعني ناس طبيعيين
بس لازم الواحد يتحكم فيها يعني هذي ما هي
يوميا مستحيل انا يوميا اروح اشتري
اولا لنفسي انا
فالوعي هو اهم خطوه
في انك تقدر تتحكم في هذه الامور
جلسه شعريه مجانيه
اتشبعت سوسو مع الفيديوهات اللي قبل ما
شاء الله
نزل احلى
بعد الحلقه اصور وكلنا مع بعض
[ضحك]
لا لا انا انا قاعد اواجه مشاكل انه
بتتكلم والله لا اصور وانزل المتابعين
اللي انت لو تقرا الكتاب حتعرف انه انا مع
هذا الشيء مع الموازنه كل زي ما تبغى بس
رتب